jetzt alter leute ich habe schon eine halbe stunde was erzählt gerade also
mindestens mindestens drei minuten oder so ich habe schon ich wundere mich die
ganze zeit warum keiner was sagt alter ich habe übelst geheult und mich
entschuldigt und so apology video gemacht und keiner hat es gehört es ist
da los das hätte ich nicht gedacht das war
garantiert wieder in windows update okay leute aber ernsthaft da muss ich
jetzt alles noch mal sagen also lass mal überlegen nicht dass ich irgendwas
vergessen habe also es gehört nein nein es als erstes was ich gesagt habe ist
ich habe den stream angefangen mit leute ich bin wieder gesund ich habe die
letzten zwei wochen immer so gucken ob ich jetzt zusammen kriegt ich habe die
letzten zwei wochen nicht viel geschrieben
hier schleimhautentzündung im magen und alles letzte woche hätte ich schon ein
bisschen schrieben können habe ich mir aber gedacht ich mache mal ein bisschen
langsam und ich musste mmo kreise greifen da ist gerade pvp event muss ich
nachher auch wieder aber und das wollte ich sagen weil ich mich selbst ein
bisschen geärgert hat und ihr wisst normalerweise geht mir das geht mir das
voll am arsch vorbei aber ich muss jetzt trotzdem mal sagen ich gelobe besserung
ich werde in nächster zeit wieder mehr streamen denn es gibt auch einige sachen
auf die ich richtig bock habt zu streamen aber ich hatte in letzter zeit
einfach nicht die weiß ich körperliche geistige motivations verfassung wie auch
immer man das lernmarkt aber und jetzt warum ich meine vm gestartet habe ist ich
wollte package updates machen euch was zeigen was wir unbedingt stream sollen
wollen stream so streben sollen müssen und zwar ich habe mir bei den china
chinesen bestellt ne ne ne ne ihr müsst das nicht es ist so wie ich sage ich
hätte ohne probleme eigentlich mehr stream können auch letzte woche schon und
Aber davor auch.
Ich habe echt wenig gestreamt in letzter Zeit.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Das trifft es ganz gut.
Wobei es gar nicht so sehr daran lag,
dass ich so wenig Bock hatte.
Sondern man muss halt irgendwie gucken,
dass das alles passt.
Und in letzter Zeit war ich ziemlich kaputt,
was so unter der Woche arbeitsmäßig angeht.
MMO Kreiselgrind.
Ich spiele ja immer noch hier Dark Freeshot.
Das ist die beste Version ohne Scheiß,
falls das Spiel jemand früher mal gespielt hat.
Das ist die beste Version von Dark Age of Camelot,
die es je gegeben hat.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es ein ehrenamtliches Freeshot-Team
innerhalb von zwei Jahren hinbekommt,
das Spiel besser zu machen als live mit sehr viel Geld
über zehn Jahre.
Oder? Also super nice.
Zumindest...
Ich habe mir was bei den China-Chinesen bestellt.
Und das müssen wir demnächst zusammenlöten im Stream.
Ja, übrigens hier gut, dass du es gesagt hast.
Ich...
Ich hätte es...
Ich habe mich schon als gewundert...
Warum sagt keiner was?
Irgendwie so ganz...
Aber ja, das erklärt es natürlich.
So, und jetzt Arch, by the way, erstmal Package-Updates.
Genau, und was ich euch zeigen wollte,
ich habe mir was bestellt.
Und zwar, ihr wisst ja, ich habe eine Mitsubishi Heavy Z...
Oh...
Aber...
Wie mal ein Lager, die ungefähr so aussieht.
Hier.
Innengeräte.
Das hängt draußen an der Wand.
So ähnlich.
Es sieht nicht ganz genauso aus.
Auch so eine ähnliche Fernbedienung.
Und ich habe im Haus solche Geräte.
Solche...
Das ist so eine Split-Klimaanlage.
Ein Teil draußen.
Dann bis zu, glaube ich, fünf Geräte drin.
Wobei ich keine fünf Geräte drin habe.
Das heißt ja noch...
Es ist noch Zeit, das Ganze zu erweitern.
Zumindest.
Ich habe ein mega nice Shit-Hub-Projekt gefunden.
Wie bei Netto, genau.
Plus kleiner.
Oder bei mir ist es eher beim Lidl.
Bei mir gibt es, glaube ich, gar kein Netto.
Ich habe ein mega nice Shit-Hub-Projekt gefunden.
Und zwar das hier.
Der hat eine Custom-Firmware für den ESP32,
beziehungsweise ESP8266, glaube ich sogar.
Ich glaube, man kann beides nehmen.
Entwickelt.
Womit man alle diese Mitsubishi Heavy-Klimaanlagen steuern kann.
Und meins ist so eins hier.
Also das, was er auch hat, was auch supported ist.
Weil ich habe immer das Problem,
ich habe ja...
Ich habe hier zwei...
Zwei Fernbedienungen dafür.
Aber jedes Mal habe ich die irgendwo hingeschmissen
und ich finde die Fernbedienung nicht.
Jetzt habe ich sie hier.
Jetzt liegt sie hier vor mir.
Aber das sind entweder die Batterien all
oder ich habe die Fernbedienung irgendwie hingeschmissen.
Und ich bin ja schon seit Jahren am Überlegen,
wie ich meine Klimaanlage
gescheit in meine Heimautomatisierung reinbekomme.
Ich habe schon mehrere Sachen ausprobiert.
Ich hatte mal so ein Broadlink IR
auf Firefox.
Ich hatte mal so einen Broadlink IR.
So eine kleine Klammer.
So eine kleine schwarze Kiste.
Wo man Infrarotsachen schicken kann.
Weil die Fernbedienung ist natürlich
letztendlich eine Infrarot-Fernbedienung.
So ein kleines, kleines, rundes Ding hatte ich da.
Ja, fuck.
Hat nicht alles unterstützt.
Die Klimaanlage ist relativ gut customizable.
Also kann es...
Ich zeige euch...
Guckt euch mal die...
Wenn ihr euch die Fernbedienung anguckt.
Die kann man nämlich noch ausklappen.
Der Klima-Hero.
Ich hoffe, die Fernbedienung ist hier einzeln drauf.
Also die Fernbedienung,
die kann man hier unten noch ausklappen.
Und da sind hier unten noch viel mehr Knöpfe drauf.
Hier unten sind nochmal doppelt so viele Knöpfe drunter.
Unter der Klappe.
Wie man da eigentlich sieht.
Und da kann man wirklich...
Ja.
Äh, nee.
Meins hat mehr Knöpfe.
Nee.
Ja, so ungefähr sieht meine Fernbedienung aus.
So, und da kann man enorm viel einstellen dran.
Also du kannst
links, rechts, vorne, hinten,
unten, automatisch,
äh, kurz,
tief, bis auf eine gewisse Grad runterkühlen,
dann in Lautlos-Modus schalten,
der Lüfter-Speed von Hand.
Den Modus kannst du umschalten,
zwischen, äh, einfach nur
ein bisschen Luft umwälzen.
Ähm, das ist so ein
Pollenfilter-Modus, kannst du da irgendwie
einschalten. Dann kannst du
heizen, kühlen
und ich glaube den Pollenfilter-Modus.
Irgendwie die vier Sachen sind es.
Und Auto, Auto noch, genau.
Zwischen umschalten und ganz viel Zeug noch.
So, ja gut, ich meine diese Timer-Funktionalität
verwende ich nicht.
Äh, Silent ist auch nice, äh, wenn's
äh, da, da ist wirklich nur ganz minimal
zum, zum, äh, Temperatur halten
und so. Zumindest, du kannst sehr viel customizen
an der
Klimaanlage, wie du das haben willst.
Und die ganzen
Infrarot-Funk-Dinger haben
das alles nur super rudimentär implementiert.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich mag die Breath of the Wild-Musik nicht.
Ich bin ja irgendwie der Einzige, aber
ich fand
den Soundtrack nicht so nice.
So, zumindest ist das hier alles nicht richtig implementiert.
Da kannst du dann teilweise nur
an-aus-Stufe einstellen und nicht
links-rechts.
Dann hatte ich was eigenes gebaut. Wir haben das ja
sogar mal hier, Woop Lords TV,
wir haben ja sogar mal im Stream
was gebaut. Klima...
...titel...
...hier.
Klimaanlagen-Steuerung haben wir ja auch mal probiert
zu bauen. Weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt mal so machen kann.
Ob ich da sogar mal eine Kamera
vorne hatte. Ja, also
alles irgendwie nicht so geil.
So, und das hier unterstützt
mehr oder weniger alles das, was man
haben will. Zumindest das, was ich auf den ersten Blick
hier schon mal sehe. Kannst dann ausschalten
und du kannst alle Modi
ordentlich durchschalten. Du kannst die
Geschwindigkeit und du kannst
auch die, wobei ich hier noch nicht so
genau checke, ob man auch vorne und hinten einstellen kann,
die Richtung der Lamellen
in der Klimaanlage einstellen. So,
und das Ding ist, das ist eine Custom-Firma
von ESP8266.
Das Problem ist bloß,
wie kriegst du den ESP8266
an die Klimaanlage
dran? Und da gibt es hier ein paar
Bilder. Ihr
seht das, so sieht die Klimaanlage auf und da kann man
das reinstecken. Das Ding ist nur, ihr seht,
da steckt kein ESP8266
direkt in der Klimaanlage, sondern
da brauchst du einen Board dafür.
Und dieses Board hat er hier auch schon
die Schematics
am Start.
Hier.
Und so ein Board habe ich mir bestellt.
Fünf Stück habe ich mir custom
anfertigen lassen bei unserem
China-Chinesen-Platin-
Fertiger schlechthin
JLC, ne
JLCPCB.
Welche Protokoll die
sprechen? Irgendein Mitsubishi-Protokoll.
Keine Ahnung. Achso, äh
SPI sprechen die, aber da drüber
irgendein Special Mitsubishi
hast du nicht gesehen. Zumindest ist das
gar nicht so einfach. Ja, also hier habe ich mir
so eine extra,
ich habe im Endeffekt die Schematics
hier hochgeladen und, oder
wie man das auch immer nennt,
ja, wie heißt denn sowas hier?
Die Layouts
quasi für die Platine
hochgeladen und die custom
fertigen jetzt für mich fünf
Platinen hiervon.
Die Elektronikteile
habe ich mir auch schon bestellt.
Wild, was es so für
Firmen gibt. Alter, das ist ein
riesen Ding hier, ja.
Die machen, glaube ich, erst seit
ein paar Jahren auch für private
Leute. Das ist so ein riesen, äh,
ja, China, Chinesen, Halbleiter,
Chip, äh, Platinen,
oh ja, wichtig.
Ein Ayaya PCB.
Ja, das ist ein riesen Ding und da kannst
du deine Sachen hochladen und
ratet mal, was das kostet,
fünf Stück custom für mich
anfertigen zu lassen. Es ist viel
billiger als bei, inklusive Versand, inklusive
Versand. 2,50, nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
20 Euro, ja, 20 Dollar.
20 Dollar. Ziemlich gut,
ziemlich gut geraten.
Wenn ich, wenn ich 100 bestellt hätte
oder 50 oder 20, wäre es wahrscheinlich
anteilmäßig noch billiger geworden.
Aber überlegt euch mal, 20 Dollar
inklusive Versand
für, äh, custom
hier, äh, gefertigte Platinen.
Was ich natürlich noch machen musste, ich musste
dann hier bei, bei Völkner habe ich das
bestellt. Ich, normalerweise bestelle
ich das, äh, sowieso Elektronikteile,
bei, ähm, wie heißen
sie, Conrad und, oh, wie heißt der andere?
Wenn ich den Namen höre, fällt es mir wieder ein.
Nee, Reichelt, Reichelt,
genau, ja.
Ja, ja, Reichelt war das.
Äh, Mouser, ja, Mouser habe ich auch schon
mal bestellt. Äh, DigiKey habe ich
noch nie bestellt. Zumindest habe ich jetzt bei Völkner
bestellt, weil die hatten alles da.
Was man braucht.
Ja, man braucht hier so ein paar, paar Dinger, man braucht,
ähm, äh, den, gut, den,
den, den Controller habe ich schon, wir brauchen Spannungswand,
wir brauchen den passenden Stecker vorne dran,
einen Levelshifter, das ist ganz wichtig,
weil die Klimaanlage liefert 12 Volt,
mit 12 Volt grillst du dein,
deine, ähm, Microcontroller-Elektronik.
Levelshifter,
ein,
Kondensator.
Alter, Leute, ich weiß nicht, was es mit
diesem Wort ist. Es ist
für mich unglaublich schwierig,
die englischen Elektronikteile
im Kopf hinzubekommen
auf Deutsch. Und wenn
ich sie dann in, in
Deutsch im Kopf habe, fallen mir die englischen Begriffe
nicht mehr ein. Kondensator,
Alter. Jetzt,
ich wusste eben noch das englische Wort,
da musste ich kurz überlegen, wie heißt der Kram auf
Deutsch? Und jetzt habe ich das deutsche Wort
im Kopf, äh, Capacitor, genau. Jetzt fällt mir
das englische Wort nicht mehr ein.
Können die das nicht irgendwie,
könnten die das nicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ähnlich
nennen? Das, was ich
das merken kann.
Ich meine, Widerstand und Resistor, das geht ja noch
irgendwie, ja, Resist, Widerstand,
aber Kondensator und Capacitor,
das kriege ich im Kopf immer nicht hin.
Und Levelshifter,
habe ich gar keine Ahnung, wie das auf Deutsch
heißt. Ähm,
Spannungsniveau
Angleicher oder so? Ich habe
absolut, wie, was heißt
Levelshifter auf Deutsch?
Wir fragen mal.
Wir fragen
mal Amazon.
Amazon Pegelwandler.
Pegelwandler.
Ja. Level
Pegelwandler, Leute.
Ja. So. Braucht man auch.
Man braucht das, dass
man die 5 Volt
auf 3,3 Volt kriegt. Also im Prinzip
hier gehen dann die 12 Volt
rein von der Klimaanlage.
Wird auf 5. 5 geht
in Input für den
Microcontroller und für die
Pins braucht man aber 3,3 Volt. Zumindest,
ich hatte ursprünglich vor,
ich habe auch schon hier mein Breadboard liegen und so
eine, so eine, wie heißt das so,
Lochplatine und so. Ich wollte das eigentlich mir
selbst zusammenlöten. Auf so einer Platine
beziehungsweise erstmal aufs Breadboard draufstecken.
Aber, das ist tatsächlich
ein bisschen eklig, weil
die Bauteile echt suboptimal
sind, um so 2D
Layouts zu bauen. Guck, der
Ground ist beispielsweise hier in der Mitte.
Du brauchst hier zweimal in der Mitte Ground.
Dann einmal hier an 3,3 Volt vom
Controller. Dann hier an die 5 Volt.
Das ist super eklig, auf so einer
2D Platine zu
routen, wo man nur rechteckig
gescheit löten kann. Also
wie gesagt, deswegen habe ich mich dazu entschieden,
einfach die Platine
mir anfertigen zu lassen von den China-Chinesen.
Zumindest, ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen,
20 Dollar
inklusive Versand. Das ist super nice,
oder? Ja, die Bauteile
insgesamt haben mich nochmal irgendwie 30 Euro
oder so gekostet. Da war das der größte
Batzen der Versand.
Weil es irgendwie
6 Euro, 5 Euro, 50 oder so DHL
Versand gekostet hat.
Wie lange hat das gedauert? Es ist noch nicht da.
Es ist noch nicht da. Deswegen sage ich ja,
das müssen wir demnächst zusammenlöten im Stream.
Es ist noch nicht da. Also ich habe
bestellt mit DHL Worldwide
Express. Gibt es da Probleme
mit dem Zoll? Ich hatte
bisher noch nie Probleme aus China, was zu
bestellen mit dem Zoll. Und die sagen auch im
Checkout, dass sie sich um alle Zollsachen kümmern.
Also,
ich habe bestellt am...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob am Donnerstag
oder am Freitag.
Ich glaube am Freitag
erst. Die Platine
ist schon fertig und in der Post. Die haben
24 Stunden Fertigungsgarantie.
Du lädst da deine Files hoch. Im Prinzip
lädst du das hier runter. Lädst das bei denen auf der Seite
hoch. Ja, musst du dich einloggen.
Habe ich jetzt hier nicht. Du lädst das hier hoch
und dann
prüfen die erstmal, ob die Platine
fertigbar ist. Könnte ja sein, dass du irgendwie Lücken
drin hast, sodass das nicht gedruckt werden kann und alles.
Und 24 Stunden,
innerhalb von 24 Stunden, fertigen die deine
Platinen. Das ist bei denen eh alles automatisiert.
Und dann packen sie es in die Post.
Und es liegt jetzt schon in der Post. Es ist aktuell
gerade am Flughafen
in
Shanghai oder Hongkong?
Moment, lass mich mal kurz gucken. Ich habe hier
die Sand...
Hongkong.
Hongkong. China People's
Republic. Alles klar.
In Hongkong ist es
gerade. Es wurde gesehen,
am 28.
April
um 11.05 Uhr
Local Time. Okay.
11.05 Uhr Hongkong
Time to CEST.
Ah, heute Nacht, okay.
Heute Nacht um 5.05 Uhr
ist mein Paket in Hongkong
angekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Chinesen
arbeiten am Sonntag.
Ob die Sachen transportieren
am Sonntag. Wenn die Sachen
transportieren am Sonntag,
besteht theoretisch
die Möglichkeit, dass es am Montag
schon kommt. Aber ich persönlich
tippe auf Mittwoch, weil
Dienstag Feiertag ist.
Ja. Du musst da
bestimmte EU-Dinge wählen.
Was?
Was ist das für eine Platine?
Das ist von
einem Projekt auf GitHub,
was man, ich zeige es dir, was man
in seine Klimaanlage einbauen kann.
Mittwoch ist Feiertag? Oh, habe ich mich vertan?
Nee, oder?
Ach nee, tatsächlich.
Mittwoch ist Feiertag.
Wie mache ich den nächsten Monat? Bin ich zu doof
für...
So?
Man muss auch nicht alles unbedingt mit der Shell machen, oder?
Ah!
Okay.
Dann habe ich Mist erzählt.
Mittwoch ist
Feiertag, tatsächlich.
Ja, korrekt.
Dann, ähm...
Dann kommt es,
denke ich mal, am
Dienstag an,
vermutlich.
Schauen wir mal.
Zumindest, wie gesagt, das ist eine Platine,
die man in seine Klimaanlage einbauen kann, so.
Und damit kann man seine Klimaanlage übers WLAN steuern
und braucht nicht mehr diese komische Fernbedienung von denen.
Ich bin schon eine ganze Weile am gucken,
wie ich meine Klimaanlage in meine Heimautomatisierung
reinkriege und das ist bis jetzt
mit Abstand das beste Projekt, was ich gesehen habe.
Ich habe da schon einiges ausprobiert,
aber...
Da machen wir Lötchamp.
Am Mittwoch, dann am Feiertag wahrscheinlich,
wenn es denn Dienstag kommt, ja.
Da löten wir uns das Ding zusammen.
Ich hoffe,
die Dinger sind in guter Qualität in der Post
am Dienstag.
So eine Platine kriege ich dann, fünf Stück.
Dann löten wir das dementsprechend zusammen.
Das dürfte nicht allzu kompliziert sein.
Einzige Sache, wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin,
ich bin ja so ein bisschen Elektronik-Noob, wisst ihr ja.
Bei solchen Symbolen
bin ich immer ein bisschen aufgeschmissen,
warum ich die Bauteile denn dann in Wirklichkeit einbauen muss.
Also das ist aber im Prinzip
auch das Einzige. Der Rest ist easy.
Der Rest passt von den Auftrücken her.
Ob ich einen Temperatursensor treffe,
weiß ich noch nicht genau.
Der Temperatursensor kommt dann hier oben dran.
Habe ich eigentlich genug.
Gut.
Ähm, und hier kommt dann der Connector dran.
Das probieren wir dann nächste Woche Mittwoch aus.
Sofern die Platinen da sind.
Aber ich bin, aber ich bin echt...
Plus ist... Echt jetzt?
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das gucke ich mir jetzt an.
Die Elektronik-Teile habe ich nämlich schon da.
Ich wollte mir das nämlich eigentlich selbst zusammen löten.
Hatte dann aber keinen Bock,
dass so 2D-mäßig
zu machen, weil das wird
viel zu groß im Vergleich zu diesem kleinen Ding.
Äh, wartet mal. Ich gucke mal.
Ist das markiert mit Plus? Wirklich?
Näh.
Ist Plus markiert.
Vielleicht ist da kein Plus drauf.
Die sagen explizit,
man soll
Polarity beachten.
Also ich zeige euch einfach mal
den...
Moment mal, Leute.
Ich, ich, ich,
ich zeige euch mal den, äh,
Ist das überhaupt ein Content?
Das ist gar kein Content. Ist es doch, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Hier, Artikelnummer 0 0 0
4 4
6 2 7 7.
Ja, so.
Äh, nein.
Nicht wirklich?
Warum stimmt die Artikelnummer nicht
mit dem Zeug was in dem Workshop?
Das ist kein
Kondensator, ja?
Hier haben wir noch was. Hier steht noch eine Zahl.
8 5 2 2 6 3
V.
Vielleicht so?
Fuck, Alter. Nichts dieser Nummern stimmt.
Okay, hier oben haben wir noch was.
6 5 8
4 9 0
0 2.
Haben die da? Sag mal, die haben doch da.
Das ist wieder was anderes.
Alter.
Was haben die da für Nummern drauf?
Okay, ich hab noch eins.
Ich hab noch eins.
P
0 0. Da stehen so viele Nummern
drauf, Alter.
4 5
3 0 9 6.
Alter, ich hab keine Ahnung, ey.
Da muss doch irgendwas... Okay, ich weiß.
Ich weiß, wie ich's rauskriege. Ich weiß, wie ich's rauskriege.
Ich hab doch hier irgendwo noch...
Moment, Leute. Ich weiß, wie ich's rauskriege.
Ich hab doch hier noch die...
Wir sind ein wenig sidetracked.
Ich hab hier noch die... die Nummer.
Von dem, was ich bestellt hab.
Ich muss mal kurz in meinen E-Mails gucken.
Wo hab ich's? Hier.
Ich hab's.
Das da müsste's sein.
Ja. Nichts von diesen Nummern
steht auf der Packung drauf, ey.
Whatever.
So.
Und da ist kein Plus irgendwie drauf.
Oder seht ihr da ein Plus?
Chatge...
Woher weiß ich jetzt?
Wir sind etwas sidetracked.
Woher weiß ich jetzt,
wie rum der hier drauf muss?
Wo der Ring... Wo ist denn da ein Ring?
Das da? Oder das da?
Die Kerbe meinste?
Ach, die Delle. Die Delle ist was?
Die Delle ist Plus?
Hier drauf?
Die Delle? Die Seite mit der Delle?
Ach, deswegen ist hier auch so eine Delle.
Ach, jetzt erkenne ich das.
Das ist da aufgemalt,
dass man erkennt, in welche Richtung
das muss.
Ich hab das da unten, was hier dieses...
Dieser Umriss
überhaupt nicht damit in Verbindung gebracht,
wie das Teil aussieht.
Okay. Alles klar.
Ja. Wie dem auch sei, das werden wir dann
am... Ich hoffe am Mittwoch.
Ich hoffe bis dahin sind alle Teile da.
Wenn wir das Löt champen.
Ja.
Ich mein, die Chancen sind gut, oder? Was denkt ihr?
Es war heute Nacht um 5 Uhr
in Hongkong, das Paket.
Das heißt, das landet jetzt im Flieger
und wird hierher geflogen.
Dann ist das
irgendwann montags da.
Und dann
haben die Zeit, das zu mir zuzustellen,
das Dienstag auszuliefern.
Wenn wir Pech haben,
wenn wir Pech haben, ist es halt erst Donnerstag da.
Naja.
Wie dem auch sei.
Das ist eines der Sachen, wo ich richtig Bock hab,
das mal mit euch auszuprobieren.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich euch das zeigen kann.
An der Klimaanlage.
Weil da liege ich mich wahrscheinlich dabei,
wenn ich hier an der Klimaanlage rumklettere
und das Ding einbaue.
Ah, mein Nas läuft.
Zumindest
muss ich vorher auf jeden Fall den Strom raus machen,
bevor ich an der Klimaanlage rumbau.
Gut.
Next.
Ach ja, hab ich euch schon gezeigt,
Twitter, wo bloß...
Ach ne, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Sorry, sorry.
Ich vergesse ja immer, dass Twitter jetzt richtig
scheiße ist, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist.
Ich zieh ne Maske an.
Ich hab sogar ne Maske hier, die ich anziehen könnte.
Nehm ich so eine hier, guck mal.
Man sieht das hier.
Äh, nein, das ist mein Stream, ich hab doch
ein Video.
Hallo Leute, hier, die Maske hab ich.
Ich hab so ne Maske
mit so nem Keks-Face drauf.
Die kann ich theoretisch sogar anziehen,
wenn ich hier rumklettere.
An der Klimaanlage.
Zumindest Chat gibt, was ich euch zeigen wollte.
Neues Low
wurde erreicht.
So tief gesunken bin ich noch nie bisher.
88,3.
Pock, oder?
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was mir gerade
einfällt? Twitter ist ja
schon ein bisschen verrückt, ja?
Twitter ist ja schon ein bisschen durch den...
geistig durch.
Ich wette mit euch, es gibt
irgendwelche Leute, die gucken sich das
Bild an und sagen,
88!
Max sendet geheime Botschaften
von seinem Twitter-Account.
Nazi confirmed!
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Die sind so durch mittlerweile auf Twitter.
Das ist so krass kek-alu
mittlerweile dort. Das würd mich echt
nicht wundern. Ich hab das schon gelesen.
Jemand auf Twitter,
dem ich folge, der leider nicht mal auf Twitter
so richtig aktiv ist, obwohl ich auch gerne Videos geguckt hab.
Der hat 88,
nämlich sein Geburtsjahr,
in seinem Twitter-Account
drinne.
Da kommen die Leute auch regelmäßig.
Was soll das immer mit der 88?
Und er sagt, Leute, ich bin 1988
geworden.
Ja, Fotosozial, du weißt
Bescheid, ja.
Wie groß ich bin? 1,74.
Und das war ganz normal.
Das war nicht irgendwie nach dem Rennen
oder sonst was. Das war
morgens, da hatte ich sogar, da hatte ich
glaub ich sogar noch Unterhose
und normale Hose und so an. Also
wahrscheinlich ist sogar noch ein Ticken weniger.
Uwe69, ja das ist
auch so ein typischer Boomer-Nickname.
Das sind die, das sind die, wisst ihr was?
Uwe69,
das sind die gleichen Leute,
die dann auf Facebook
irgendwelche Eierwitze
zu Ostern posten.
Und ihr wisst schon,
und ihr wisst schon,
Moment,
sonst klappt das, sonst klappt das nicht.
Und ihr wisst schon,
welche Emotes
der dann da reinpostet.
Uwe69
macht Eierwitze
zu Ostern und postet dieses
Emoji dabei.
Das ist typischer, typischer
Boomer-Facebook-Homer.
Ja.
So sieht's aus.
88,3.
So tief bin ich noch nie gesunken
bisher. Also, ich mein,
als ich auf die Welt gekommen bin und so,
natürlich, bevor jetzt jemand meint,
actually, das stimmt nicht Max, du warst schon mal
leichter. Ja, ich war schon mal leichter.
Aber ich war die letzten 15
Jahre nicht mehr so leicht.
Ich würd sagen,
wahrscheinlich so seit ich,
keine Ahnung, 20
oder so bin, und jetzt bin ich 39,
war ich nicht mehr so leicht, okay?
Und vor allem,
jetzt kommt's ja, nicht mehr nur nicht
so leicht, sondern so gut in Form.
Ich bin ja nicht nur leicht,
ich bin ja auch noch gleichzeitig gut in Form.
Und das hatte ich locker seit
der Hälfte meines Lebens nicht mehr.
Sagen wir, runden wir mal auf,
ich bin seit 25 Jahren,
war ich nicht mehr so gut in Form
und so leicht. Ich bin
heute Morgen wieder gerannt.
Relativ, relativ
easy. Ne, Triathlon,
äh, Triathlon werd ich nicht machen. Ich mag
mittlerweile Schwimmen nicht mehr. Früher war das
mein Lieblingshobby, schwimmen zu gehen.
Ich konnte auch kilometerweit schwimmen, überhaupt kein Ding.
Aber ich hatte, ich hatte
sogar die, diese frei, nicht
Freischwimmer, wie nennt man das?
Das, was es in Bronze, Silber,
Gold gibt.
Ist das Freischwimmer? Freischwimmer in
Gold, gibt es sowas?
Diese, diese Abzeichen, die man sich dann so ganz
stolz auf die Badehose nähen
hat lassen von der Mutter.
Ja, schwimm ab, sowas, ja.
Zumindest, ich wollte mal, ich muss mal
kurz grad in meine, Seepferdchen
hatte ich nicht, ich hatte nie ein Seepferdchen, weil
ich hatte ein Pinguin.
Ich hab das, ich hab das in einem Offenbacher
Schwimmbad gemacht, das war im Prinzip ein Seepferdchen.
Aber die haben keine Seepferdchen
vergeben, die haben ein Pinguin vergeben.
Moment, wir gucken mal.
Ob's es noch gibt.
Schwimmabzeichen, Gold.
Jawoll.
Gold hab ich übrigens dann nicht gemacht,
Silber hatte ich, Silber.
Auf Ebay kann man das mittlerweile kaufen.
Keckweh.
Warum? Ich mein ernsthaft,
ohne Scheiß, wenn ich sowas auf Ebay
kaufe und mir auf die Badehose
montiere. Seriously, das ist einfach
gecheatet. Das ist echt
krass gecheatet. Das Abzeichen
auf Ebay zu kaufen.
Das ist, das ist wirklich unehrenhaft
schon. Ja, ich hatte das
auch immer auf der Badehose damals.
Ja. So, und
Schwimmabzeichen, ich hatte nen Pinguin.
Gibt's das
noch? Ja, sowas.
Genau, sowas irgendwie in der Richtung hatte ich.
Ich glaub, irgendwie so. Der sah ziemlich doof
aus, aber so sah er nicht aus. Ich glaube, so.
Irgendwie, irgendwie sowas hatte ich.
Pinguin.
Bis heute gab's kein. So, und
ich hab das später gemacht bis dahin.
Dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Okay, Schwimmabzeichen, Silber, Anforderungen.
Da muss ich mal gucken. Das war, das war easy.
Ja, das, das war easy.
Ähm, so.
Seepferdchen.
Freischwimmer ist Bronze.
Silber.
Okay.
Die theoretische Prüfung erfasst die
Kenntnisse von Baderegeln, Verhalten zur Selbstrettung,
zum Beispiel Verhalten bei Erschöpfung, Lösung von Kräften.
Äh, keine Ahnung, ob ich
diesen theoretischen Prüfungsteil machen musste.
Damals schon
Linux-Enjoyer, genau.
Okay, praktische Prüfungsleistung.
Sprung kopfwärts vom Beckenrand
und 20 Minuten schwimmen.
Ja, das hab ich. Easy.
Ich konnte Stunden schwimmen zu dem damaligen
Zeitpunkt. Dieserzeit sind mindestens
400 Meter zurück.
Alter, krass, oder?
Wie schafft man das nicht?
400 Meter, wie schafft man das in unter...
Naja.
Äh, davon 300 Meter in Bauch...
oder Rückenlage in einer erkennbaren
Schwimmart und 100 Meter in der anderen
Körperlage. Okay?
Zweimal circa 2 Meter tief tauchen von
der Wasseroberfläche...
Ja? Da kann ich drei nennen, das hab ich gemacht.
10 Meter Strecken tauchen mit Abstoß...
Ja, easy. Sprung aus 3 Meter Höhe.
Oder zwei verschiedene Sprünge aus 1 Meter Höhe.
Ja, easy. Nice.
Da war ich damals ganz stolz drauf,
dieses Ding auf der Badehose zu haben.
Aber das Gold...
Gold hab ich da nie gemacht, da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Aber es war schon nice.
Ja, und jetzt
hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock mehr schwimmen zu gehen.
Zumindest, ich wollte, ich wollte ja mal
schnell. Lass mich mal ganz kurz in meine
App gucken. Also ich konnte
jetzt ja drei Wochen nix machen.
Ich bin einmal kurz ein bisschen versucht zu joggen
und einmal 30 Minuten
Fahrrad gefahren.
Drei Wochen lang hab ich quasi nix gemacht, weil
halt Schleimhautentzündung im Magen und so.
Das war echt scheiße, da sich mit groß bewegen.
Ich hab am Freitag wieder angefangen.
Langsame Runde.
Dann gestern zwei Stunden Fahrrad fahren.
Heute knapp eine Stunde.
50 Minuten.
Heute hab ich 7,55
Kilometer.
6 Minuten 34
pro Kilometer. Das ist so
recht
zügig.
Aber ne ganze Ecke
noch von dem weg, was ich kann,
wenn ich wirklich all out renne.
Sodass ich deadge bin danach.
So.
50, also
49, 31.
So und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
was
die App meint.
Okay, sogar plus Performance.
Guck, drei Wochen nix gemacht und meine App meint
plus Performance. Na dann.
Audersache zwar nicht so ganz,
aber gut.
Nice. Also ist anscheinend nicht so viel
verloren gegangen in drei Wochen.
Gut, dann fangen wir mal mit dem normalen
Programm an, würde ich sagen. Programm?
Alter, als wäre das super krass.
Geplant hier
schon im Vorfeld irgendwie was überlegt.
Ne, wir gucken uns mal an, was auf Shithub
trendet. Moin.
Sorry, falls
ich irgendjemanden übersehen habe hier.
Glaube ich aber nicht.
Ein Nachteil hat das,
wenn man drei Wochen sich nicht richtig bewegt hat
und jetzt wieder anfängt. Man hat
übertrieben Hunger. Ich hab jetzt Hunger.
Ich hab was gefuttert,
bevor ich losgerannt
bin und jetzt könnte ich schon wieder
zwei Pizzas fressen, ey.
Übelst Hunger.
Aber ich muss jetzt noch warten, so bis 12.
Außerdem muss ich immer noch ein bisschen auf meinen
Magen achten, dass es nicht wieder
anfängt.
Ich sehe gerade,
vor 20 Minuten ist mir der Stuttgart Champ
gefolgt. Der hat mal einen guten Namen.
Der Stuttgart Champ.
Bist du noch am Start?
Das könnte ein Fake Account von mir sein.
Der Stuttgart Champ.
Ja, Arzi, Dan, Dankeschön für eure Subs,
falls ich nicht gesagt hab.
Blixar hat auch letzten subscribed.
Sehe ich hier noch in der History.
War ich aber nicht da.
Heute keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Äh, doch.
Tatsächlich, heute
Nudeln mit Lachs, allerdings
mit Frankfurter grüner Soße.
Grühsoß.
Dabei.
Das ist immer gut verträglich
und ich will nicht so viel fettigen
Kramfutter, nachdem ich so Magenprobleme hatte.
Was'n das?
Das ist...
Eine...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die Base ist davon.
Letztendlich
sind das irgendwie 12 verschiedene
Kräutersorten in so'n...
Wahrscheinlich saure Sahne oder so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das macht.
So sieht das aus.
Sieht jetzt hier vielleicht nicht so appetitlich
drauf aus, aber...
Das ist so ne Kräutersoße.
Das ist so hessische...
Hessische...
Nationalspezialität.
So was geht nicht. In Bayern gibt's Weißwürste.
Dafür.
Und anderes Zeug.
Das ist ja auch was hessisches.
So, lasst mal kurz gucken, was auf Shithub trendet.
Ähm, Leute, ich muss mal kurz noch was zu trinken holen.
Ich bin in einer Minute wieder da.
Kurz mal leer trinken.
Ich renn mal kurz schnell runter und hol noch nen Tee.
Und? Chat?
Ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich hab gesehen,
auf der Treppe liegt noch
ein nicht
geöffnetes Amazon-Paket.
Da muss ich mal kurz reingucken,
weil ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich wieder bestellt hab.
Ähm, da muss ich mal kurz
reingucken. Wir machen jetzt
quasi ein schnelles Unboxing, ohne dass
ihr's seht.
Das ist nicht sonderlich satisfying, ich weiß.
Aber ich muss jetzt mal kurz reingucken.
Also, was haben wir denn hier? Ah, nice!
Da wart ich ja schon drauf.
Guckt mal, da wollte ich nämlich ein bisschen mit rum
experimentieren.
Und zwar ist das ein...
Sonoff...
Zig...
Bidongel.
Allerdings
die...
Diese Variante.
Mit dem neuen Chipsatz.
Da wollte ich die ganze Zeit nämlich schon mal
ein bisschen damit rumbasteln.
Der kann nämlich mit der passenden
Software ZigBee
und Thread über den
gleichen Stick machen.
Den kann man flashen
mit Custom Firm... ne, das ist keine Custom
Firma, das ist eigentlich Blödsinn.
Das ist glaube ich... wobei,
bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das
nicht vielleicht doch Custom Firm... zumindest gibt es da eine
Firmware dafür, dass der
Stick im Endeffekt nur, sagen wir mal,
als Antenne fungiert.
Und die ZigBee und Thread Logik
passiert dann in einer
Software auf dem jeweiligen Host-System.
Allerdings kann man damit dann
quasi, dadurch dass dieser Stick im Endeffekt nur
als, sagen wir mal in Anführungszeichen, Antenne fungiert,
kann man damit ZigBee
und Thread in einem Gerät machen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf, weil ich gehe davon aus,
dass ich über kurz oder lang
irgendwie Thread-Geräte bei mir in
die Heimautomatisierung einbauen werde. Und damit
wollte ich tatsächlich ein bisschen rumbasteln.
Genau. So. Stick.
ZigBee Stick.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier Schönes?
Was ist denn das?
Fuck. Du bist zu doof, den zu
flashen. Ja dann.
Let's go. Gut, dass du's
sagst.
Äh...
Sonoff E-Dongle flashen.
Ich muss das Ding auch flashen.
Da können wir das mal
zusammen ausprobieren im Stream.
So und dann habe ich hier noch ein paar Sachen, die sehen ehrlich gesagt
relativ unspektakulär aus.
Ein, zwei Packages.
Zwei Packages.
Oh.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich nicht der Rede.
CX4XH
5 Pin Connectors.
Hier. So was.
Bloß auf beiden Seiten schon fertig.
So was hier.
Ein Packages mit
ich glaube 10
5 Pins
und ein Package mit
jeweils 2 2 Pin, 2
3 Pin, 2
4 Pin, 2 5 Pin, 2 6 Pin.
Weil diese Dinger braucht man immer mal wieder.
Diese Kabel.
Und als letztes
habe ich noch. Was ist das?
Ich glaube das habe ich für meinen Bastel
Bastel Krams hier.
Ah.
Schon fertig vorkonfektionierte
Breadboard.
Steckkabel.
Ja das habe ich mir wahrscheinlich mal auf gut Glück bestellt.
Weil ich die anderen nicht mehr
gefunden habe.
Ja das
ist jetzt nicht so.
So was hier ist
das.
Breadboard Kabel Set.
So was hier in der
Richtung genau.
Bloß nicht das.
Es sieht eher so aus.
Schadet nichts.
Da mal ein paar auf Lager zu haben.
Ist ja einfach meine Bastel
Kiste ist es nicht.
Schublade schmeißen.
Und gut ist.
Ich habe extra so 2 Schränke
mit durchsichtigen Schubladen
für den ganzen Bastel Kram.
Das ich von draußen reingucken kann.
Und ich habe eine Kiste da ist dieser ganze Elektronik Kram
für Bastel.
Nicht alles da sind so Sachen wie Widerstände drin
oder Pin Header oder solche Kabel und so.
Das man es findet.
Und den ganzen Sensor Kram den habe ich
in so einem ganz kleinen
Sortierschrank von ich glaube
Stanley Schrank oder so.
Weiß nicht.
So was hier. Ja genau.
So was hier.
So was hier oben.
Das ist für Sensoren ist das super.
Da habe ich einen mit Ultraschallsensoren
drin. Einen mit Temperatursensoren.
Da findet man den Kram wieder.
Ist bei mir nicht wirklich ordentlich.
Aber ich suche einfach immer viel zu lang diesen ganzen Kram.
Deswegen habe ich das mal ein bisschen
ordentlich gemacht.
Ok. Gut. Das war in meiner
Amazon Package drin.
Alles klar.
Exzellent.
Da können wir Github Trends uns angucken.
Aerochild. Danke für den Sub.
So. Also was trendet denn diese Woche
auf Github?
Lass uns mal gucken. Lama. Ja. AI.
Was sonst?
Facebook Lama.
So. Meta.
Was macht eigentlich
das Metaverse so?
Außer keine Beine
haben.
Oh. AI. AI.
AI.
AI. AI.
AI. AI. AI.
Äh.
Ah.
Emulator für. Ja.
Ähm. Emulator für iOS.
Den man über Custom App Stores.
Wobei. Gibt es den mittlerweile auch im offiziellen
App Store? Wahrscheinlich nicht oder?
Über Custom App Stores installieren kann.
Man streng genommen ist es ja nicht illegal
einen Emulator anzubieten.
Es ist illegal sich die ROMs
kopiergeschützt zu besorgen.
Also streng genommen
ist ja der
Hersteller des Emulators
fein raus.
Wenn er nicht irgendwelche
strittigen Sachen drin hat.
So wie
Yuzu hießen die.
Die sicherlich anderweitig schon wieder back sind.
Okay. Also.
Räumlich.
Müsste ich vielleicht da mal ausprobieren.
Das Metaverse sucht noch seine
Existenzberechtigung. Ja die habe ich noch nie verstanden.
VR Chat. Wenn man auf
sowas. Das verstehe ich halt nicht.
Wenn man auf sowas steht. Ja.
Dann ist VR Chat einfach das beste
was es gibt.
Ich meine die meisten Leute haben von VR Chat glaube ich
nur. Äh. Was auch immer.
Ugandan Knuckles mitbekommen.
Falls sich da noch irgend jemand dran erinnert.
Aber. Also. Wenn jemand
sowas mag. Dann ist
einfach VR. Warum sollte der irgendwas mit
Warum sollte der irgendwas mit
Metaverse von Facebook
machen.
Wobei Facebook ja auch eher auf die Business Sache
abzielt. Ja.
Und da ist VR Chat halt nicht unbedingt
zu gebrauchen für. Ich glaube niemand
möchte ein
seriöse
sagen wir mal irgendwie
irgendeine Besprechung
in VR Chat abhalten.
Wir haben alle nur
Sicherheitskopien von unseren eigenen Sachen selbstverständlich.
Die ganzen
Sachen die es im Internet zum Download gibt.
Die sind ja eigentlich da gar nicht zum Download.
Das sind einfach nur Sicherheitskopien.
Falls das Original mal kaputt geht.
Man sich das wieder selbst
Recovern kann.
War damals auch schon so.
Waren immer nur Sicherheitskopien.
Streng genommen. So was haben wir denn
sonst noch. AI.
Äh. Keine Ahnung.
AI. AI.
AI.
China Chinesen Kram.
Alter. AI.
Also diese Woche ist glaube ich die schlechteste
Woche ever bei Github Trends.
Das sind ja im Endeffekt
95%
Lama und AI
Kram gewesen. Meine Güte.
Das ist ja für'n Arsch.
Gucken wir mal was in der .Net Welt so
trendet. Okay.
Nichts spannendes.
Das hat sich nicht gelohnt
diese Woche da rein zu gucken.
Nämlich ist so eine
Fotoverwaltung oder?
Wenn ich den Namen sehe.
Ja.
Bin ich. Warum?
Also ich benutze die eigentlich so gut wie nicht mehr.
Ich hab da noch ein Account.
Ich hab da noch.
Ich hab da halt noch ein Account.
Was ganz nice ist
für temporäre Kreditkarten
die man halt einmalig
braucht.
Ich hab grad versucht die App zu öffnen. Das hat mich ausgelockt.
Ich werd mich da wahrscheinlich nie wieder einloggen.
Keine Ahnung.
Also meine Stonks hab ich allerdings bei
Scalable.
Und da muss ich grad mal reingucken.
Was die Stonks so machen.
Ja. Geht so.
Warum fragst du?
Also ich war da ja nie großartig.
Ich war da immer nur für temporäre Kreditkarten.
Wenn man halt nicht seine jahrelang gültigen
Kreditkarten bei irgendeinem China-Chinesen-Shop
oder so hinterlegen will.
Ja ja ist es.
Wie gesagt ich verdiene ja mein Geld auch zum größten Teil
aktuell mit Crypto-Blockchain-Sachen.
Nicht als
Crypto-Bro oder so.
Wo ich auf Twitter die neuesten Shitcoins promote.
Sondern ich arbeite bei
einer Versicherung in Frankfurt und dort ist
Blockchain-Technologie und Crypto-Assets
wie man es so schön nennt.
Mittlerweile auch ein Thema.
Was aber auch bedeutet, wenn es dort mittlerweile
ein Thema ist, dass das was wir machen
wahrscheinlich schon wieder hoffnungslos
nicht mehr im Trend ist.
Weil du kannst auf eine Sache
eine Sache kannst du sicher sein.
Wenn die großen Frankfurter Versicherungen
und Banken anfangen mit irgendeinem Thema
dann ist das meistens schon wieder
bei den coolen Leuten out.
So, you're done?
Github war
nix spannendes diesmal drinnen.
Nein nein
das Goat hier ist gar nix on.
Lass mal schauen, was haben wir denn hier schönes?
Oh.
Ich weiß nicht warum, aber irgendwie muss ich das jetzt angucken.
Wie sie mit dem Poppes wackelt.
Das hat Chico auch immer gemacht,
wenn sie irgendwas fangen wollte.
Und die hier auch.
Und hopp.
Und hat sie es erwischt?
Nein, hat sie nicht erwischt.
Ja,
das machen sie manchmal, wenn sie super aufgeregt sind.
Zum Beispiel
wo Katzen sowas super
wo die komplett
ausflippen können, nicht alle.
Aber die
meine Vorletzte ist da immer komplett ausgeflippt.
Die
die hier.
Wenn die Vögel durchs Fenster gesehen hat
und ist nicht rausgekommen.
Wenn die Vögel quasi
wenn die in der Küche am Fenster gesessen hat
und im Hof waren Vögel
und die wollte raus, aber die Tür war zu und was auch immer
da ist die voll aus, da ist die Firma aus.
Da saß die immer da und hat genau sowas gemacht.
Genau solche Geräusche.
Ich will dahin, ich will dahin, ich will dahin, ich kann nicht.
Ich will dahin.
Ja.
Oder wenn irgendwas im Hof rumkrabbelt und sie kann grad nicht.
Oh.
Was machst du hier auf meinem Rasen, Alter?
Piss dich. Piss dich, Alter.
Ja.
Stärkste Katze überhaupt, muss man natürlich immer demonstrieren.
Man sollte bei sowas
nicht auf die blöde Idee kommen.
Hier Leute.
Man sollte hier nicht versuchen
an den Bauch zu fassen.
Dann hast du die Krallen in der Hand.
Jetzt das dumme Ding kann man gar nicht richtig fangen.
Jetzt erstmal schlafen eine Runde.
Das war jetzt viel zu anstrengend.
Meine hat immer,
wenn die sich so gejuckt hat
und du hast sie dann mitgekratzt
so an der Seite,
wenn du gesagt hast, aha, da scheint es zu jucken,
dann hast du sie,
da hat sie sich vor dich gestellt und du musstest sie kratzen so
am Kopf
und da hat die, wenn du sie gekratzt hast
am Kopf, hat die mit ihrem Bein
immer so mitgemacht so.
Die konnte das irgendwie im Kopf nicht trennen
mit, es juckt mich,
ich werde gekratzt,
aber ich bin es nicht selbst.
Die hat dann immer mit ihrem Bein mitgeschwungen,
wenn du sie am Kopf gekratzt hast.
Sie musste sich aber immer zusammenreißen,
weil sie einer sonst die Hand gekratzt hätte,
wenn sie das Bein wirklich am Kopf gemacht hätte.
Die hast du dann quasi,
die hast du dann quasi am Kopf gekratzt
und die hat permanent, während du sie am Kopf gekratzt hast,
mit ihrem Bein so
immer versucht mitzukratzen,
aber ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht,
ich muss mich mitkratzen.
Das hat sie irgendwie überfordert.
Dieses Ende,
dieses Android-Smartphone
kann mein Desktop-PC ersetzen.
Ja, Chibait, Alter, Chibait.
Kann es nicht.
Weil man ein Desktop-PC hat,
nicht nur um einen großen Bildschirm zu haben,
sondern halt auch um damit Desktop-Sachen zu machen.
Ordentliche Maus-Tastatur-Bedienung
mit der passenden Software dafür,
die auf Maus- und Tastatur-Bedienung ausgelegt ist.
Quick look at my
Homelab, da bin ich immer dabei.
Jeff, zeig uns
dein Homelab.
Sowas finde ich immer spannend.
So, let's go take a look at
the Homelab.
We're going downstairs.
The ground level is
right about here, so something down the stairs will be
underground.
Der ist ja schon am Schnaufen,
beim Loslaufen.
So wie ich früher auch.
This door here goes to the secret lab.
Früher war ich auch schon immer am Schnaufen, beim Treppelaufen.
Mittlerweile geht es eigentlich.
Und was ich gemerkt habe ist, also ich war früher auch
der richtige Kona, was das
angeht. Was ich auch gemerkt
habe ist, seitdem ich regelmäßig
Fahrradfahren gehe, wenn ich
jetzt die Treppe schnell hochlaufe,
es brennt nicht mehr
in den Oberschenkeln.
So schnell. Wenn ich jetzt vom ersten
in den fünften Stock laufe oder so, volle Pulle,
dann immer noch. Aber nicht mal bei
normalen Treppen, wo man mal schnell
hochläuft, merke
ich dann gar nicht mehr danach in den Oberschenkeln.
Merke ich wird ein bisschen warm, aber das war's.
Hast du mittlerweile wieder ein neues Bike?
Ja, habe ich. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen.
Wir machen das auch. Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad.
Wenn man das jetzt richtig schreibt.
Omega Keckel. Max Fahrrad.
Blöde Idee
auf die Rose Webseite zu verlinken.
Man sieht es hier oben in der
URL noch, was es für eins ist.
Wenn man danach sucht, findet man es wahrscheinlich.
Google Cash gibt es nicht mehr, oder?
Wisst ihr, das finde ich so
scheiße.
So richtig scheiße.
Anders kann ich sagen, dass Google
den Cash abgeschaltet hat.
Ich fand legit den
Das ist das falsche,
aber ich fand
legit den Google Cash
eines der besten Features
von Google überhaupt.
Wir gucken mal, ob Internet
Archive sowas hat.
Äh
Wait a minute.
Nein, ja.
Ah, hier. Nice.
Haben wir einmal archiviert.
Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Vielleicht können wir den Link anpassen.
High IQ
Chatkes
Mods
Ja, das habe ich am Start hier.
Habe ich nicht bezahlt.
Das war
günstiger.
Hat glaube ich nur 2.300 Euro gekostet.
Weil
das nicht so das aller aktuellste
Modell mehr ist.
Allerdings hat Shimano
noch keine neue elektronische Schaltung
vorgestellt mit 1x12
für Gravel Bikes.
Das kommt irgendwann im Sommer.
Deswegen, ich habe noch die alte
2x11
nicht 1x12
oder 2x12.
Und ich habe das Fahrrad aber auch schon selbst
auseinander genommen und habe hier hinten eine größere Kassette
reingemacht. Hier hinten habe ich jetzt
40, 11,
46 und nicht 11,36
oder so, was da normal ist.
Was sehr nice ist, kommen wir jetzt einfach
in den Berg hoch. Zumindest das ist
das Fahrrad, was ich aktuell habe.
Da ist die Seite, wo ich mal bookmarken muss.
Ach ja, und übrigens war als Update
die Versicherung
von dem Unfall
letztes Jahr. Mein Fahrrad ist ja Schrott.
Also wer es nicht mitgekriegt hat. Ich hatte einen Unfall letztes Jahr
mit meinem Fahrrad.
Und da hat mich eine
auf dem Fahrradweg
der Vorfahrt von mir
von der Seite umgefahren.
Also ich hatte Vorfahrt, die hatte ein Schild
Vorfahrt achten und hat mich trotzdem von der Seite
umgefahren. Und das Fahrrad
ist kaputt. Gutachter sagt Totalschaden.
Restwert 80 Euro oder sowas.
Und die
Versicherung hat das auch anerkannt, hat keinen Einspruch, aber die haben
bis jetzt immer noch nicht alles bezahlt. Und es wird
tagtäglich teurer für die.
Ausfall plus Anwaltskosten
werden bei jedem Brief, den er da hinschreibt, mehr.
Die haben mittlerweile knapp die Hälfte bezahlt,
aber den Rest immer noch nicht.
Mittlerweile ist da so
viel Geld zusammen, kommt da so viel Geld zusammen,
dass ich fast das neue Fahrrad
ähm, also dass es
fast das doppelte oder so ist.
Das ist dann quasi ein Fahrrad umsonst.
Richtig dumm.
Ich mein, vor allem, mich juckt es nicht.
Der Anwalt kümmert sich drum.
Ich hab überhaupt
bekommst du das dann oder der Anwalt?
Der Anwalt bekommt sein Geld.
Davon, ja.
Ich bekomm aber auch mehr,
weil ich hab ja quasi
dadurch einen Ausfall so.
Also aktuell ist es das Doppelte ungefähr nur
wegen dem Gutachter und den Anwaltskosten,
der Rest noch nicht. Also das krieg ich nicht alles.
Aber
insgesamt,
wenn die sich noch ein bisschen Zeit lassen,
wer weiß, vielleicht hat sich das
neue Fahrrad dann auch bezahlt.
Ja, aber ist eigentlich schon affig, wenn du das überlegst.
Die hat mich letztes Jahr irgendwann im November
oder so, Anfang November umgefahren
und es ist jetzt
Mai.
Und die haben immer noch nicht bezahlt.
Über ein halbes Jahr ist es halt voll
von Arsch. Überlegt euch mal jemand,
bräuchte das, wäre da wirklich drauf angewiesen,
es wäre vielleicht was Wichtigeres als ein Fahrrad.
Der hätte nicht genug Kohle mal auf der
hohen Kante sich ein neues zu kaufen.
Bist halt ganz schön
am Arsch.
Ich verstehe auch
gar nicht, warum das erlaubt ist, über ein halbes Jahr,
wenn es unstrittig ist,
das hinzuziehen.
Ja, aber die sind dumm, das kostet die nur mehr.
Die sind richtig dumm.
Nee, gar nicht.
Die haben ja schon gesagt, sie
stimmen unseren
Forderungen zu und die haben auch schon teilweise
überwiesen. Erst haben sie sich rausgeredet
mit, ja, sie wollen keine
Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen, warum auch immer,
obwohl man es ganz klar in der Rechnung gesehen hat,
dass ich das als Privatperson gekauft habe, dann doch.
Dann haben sie da wieder was vergessen.
Oder was heißt vergessen? Vergessen haben die sich
absichtlich nicht mitbezahlt. Ich weiß nicht, warum die so blöd sind.
Und mir ist es vollkommen
egal. Ich habe mir ein neues Fahrrad gekauft
mittlerweile. Der Anwalt macht das. Ich habe
da keine Aufwände mit. Ich kriege im Endeffekt
nur mehr Geld und die
verlieren Kohle. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
warum die da so lange für brauchen.
Der Anwalt freut sich,
weil er für jeden Brief
und alles gut bezahlt wird.
Die haben nur Nachteile dadurch.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die so lahm sind. Die sind so dumm.
Und ich bin so froh, dass ich
das dem Anwalt gegeben habe. Ich habe mir ja
am Anfang gedacht, ey, die Sache ist so klar
und auf
Autos und allem so klar, da brauchst du keinen Anwalt.
Aber schon einen Tag nach meinem
Unfall habe ich mir das mal überlegt
und habe mir gedacht, doch.
Doch, du lässt das ein Anwalt
machen.
Du hast keinen Bock, dich mit denen rumzustreiten.
Also direkt
nächste Woche zum Anwalt.
Nö.
Nö, Anwalt hier bei mir um die Ecke.
Ich meine,
ich hatte ein bisschen Stress damit, dass ich zu einem Gutachter
rennen musste, was die gegnerische
Versicherung sicherlich auch gemacht hätte.
Aber wer weiß, wie objektiv dann
denen ihr Gutachter ist.
Ich bin so ein Gutachter.
Das hat auch irgendwie knapp 1.000 Euro oder so
gekostet, das ist ein fucking Gutachten.
Aber gut, soll er ruhig abrechnen.
Der hat das ja auch super ausführlich gemacht.
Ich muss es eh nicht bezahlen, ist mir also wurscht.
Ja.
Also es ist echt komplett
witzlos.
Ich finde es halt nur affig, dass es überhaupt
erlaubt ist, das so lange rauszuzögern.
Mir ist es jetzt persönlich wurscht, ja.
Für mich ist es sogar noch gut,
umso länger die brauchen.
Aber es mag ja durchaus Leute geben, die darauf angewiesen sind
und wo es um was Wichtigeres geht als ein Fahrrad.
Ja und das sind Kleinbeträge
für die. Was juckt die denn
im Endeffekt? Irgendwie 3.000,
na mittlerweile sind wir glaube ich bei 5.000
oder so mit allem drum und dran.
Aber was juckt die das überhaupt?
Die können froh sein,
dass ich nicht noch hier die
Fußballtaktik gemacht habe und mich
hingeschmissen habe.
Mein Bein! Ich bin so schwerfällig!
Ich bin so verletzt,
dass ich da irgendwie noch jetzt
drei Wochen
Verdienstausfall und whatever.
Ich war noch nicht mal krank deswegen.
Ich kann doch nicht froh sein.
Die hätten noch viel mehr bezahlen
müssen im Zweifelsfall.
Wenn wirklich was gewesen wäre.
Nein, nein.
Kein Schmerzensgeld und nix
habe ich auch nicht vor.
Aber
wenn es ein bisschen anders ausgegangen wäre,
hätte das durchaus sein können. Oder einer
sagen wir mal,
der es vielleicht darauf anlegt.
Die sind einfach dumm.
Ganz ehrlich, die hätten am meisten Geld
mitgespart. Hätten die mich montags
angerufen, hätten sie gesagt, Herr Max,
Geld ist schon auf dem Weg.
Passt alles.
Und dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich
nicht mal zum Anwalt.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ich muss auch sagen,
AI-Code-Sachen
Ich bin noch nicht
komplett überzeugt. Ich benutze das manchmal
für Sachen wie Ansible-Files checken
und sowas.
Es liegt aber auch daran, dass ich
ganz am Anfang mal ein paar Sachen mit ChatGPT
probiert habe.
Und
das hat so einen Scheiß dazu halluziniert.
Methoden, die es nicht gibt.
Und als ich ChatGPT gesagt habe,
das gibt es nicht, hat es mir eine Windows-Forms-Anwendung
gebaut, obwohl ich eigentlich eine Konsolenanwendung wollte.
Ja, haben wir.
Haben wir.
Wäre es sicherlich nicht wert gewesen, ja.
Chat, habt ihr schon,
habt ihr schon mal was gebrochen?
Ich noch nie.
Ich hatte noch nie
irgendwas.
Ich überlege gerade nicht, dass ich jetzt
Scheiße erzähle, ob nicht vielleicht irgendwas Kleines war,
wo ich gerade nicht dran denke.
Zumindest nichts Großes.
Also keine Arme, Beine und so.
Ich hatte mal vor kurzem
die
blöde Vermutung, ich habe mir die Nase gebrochen.
Habe ich aber glücklicherweise doch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht mehr,
was ich gemacht habe, aber ich habe im Flur
alles gebastelt.
Und bin beim Aufstehen
also
das muss man erstmal schaffen.
Das muss man erstmal schaffen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das geht.
Hier ist das, oh geil, geil Max.
Hier geht es um ein Geländer.
Hier geht es um ein Geländer lang.
Hier geht die Treppe runter.
Haben wir uns, glaube ich, ganz gut vorstellen.
Und ich muss irgendwo
hier was gemacht haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung was.
Zumindest habe ich mich
gedreht.
Ich habe hier irgendwas gemacht
und habe mich so gedreht.
Und meine Nase,
also wenn das hier meine Nase ist.
Big, big nose.
Habe ich die quasi
aus der
Drehbewegung
hier
drangehauen gegen das
Geländer.
Oh, da bin ich umgekippt.
Das war so richtig wie einmal
voll in die Fresse geschlagen.
Und da habe ich gedacht, fuck, Alter.
Nicht Nase gebrochen.
Aber
war zum Glück nichts.
Ich hatte ein bisschen
Panik erstmal.
Die drehen ja
übelst die Augen und alles.
War zum Glück nichts.
Ich habe mir
noch nie was gebrochen.
Ich habe es auch nicht vor nachzuholen.
Und das obwohl, wie ich klein war.
Ich bin Bäume geklettert.
Ich habe allen möglichen
gefährlichen Kram gemacht früher.
Aber nie was passiert.
Immer gut ausgegangen.
Schmerzhafter als Brüche.
Das kommt ganz entscheidend auf den
Bruch an und auf die Prellung.
Ja, ich weiß, das habe ich auch schon
gehört, aber
das kommt bestimmt immer auf den Einzelfall an.
Und
gut.
Wir wollten uns ja das Homelab von dem Typ angucken.
Hast du schon die diesjährige Abschlussprüfung für den Physiker
gesehen?
Nein.
Aber ich darf die wie immer nicht im Stream zeigen,
weil die Copyright gekopyrightet ist.
Wenn jetzt jemand zufällig eine Frage
in den Chat postet,
da kann ich natürlich nichts dagegen machen.
Man kann die Frage ja ein bisschen verändern,
dass es nicht 1 zu 1 die Frage ist.
So.
Dann schauen wir uns doch mal das Homelab von Jeff an.
Radiation Air
Danger Laser
Oh, warum?
Da ist wahrscheinlich weder Laser
noch Radiation Area drinnen.
Der findet das einfach, glaube ich, keck
keck wait.
Warning, no stupid people
Wäre denn das jetzt auch jemand, der Win doof
sagt? Okay, Win doof
sagen die Leute nur in Deutsch.
Wie sagen denn die Amis dazu eigentlich?
Wenn die
Windows falsch aussprechen wollen absichtlich.
Also
Und wisst ihr was
Windows, okay.
Was besonders cringe ist?
Mini weich Win doof.
Alter, das ist so krasser
Boomer Humor, da cringet sich mir immer alles.
Fühlst du dich manchmal
einsam? Ne, ich hab doch den Twitch Chat.
Und jetzt mal auf etwas
realistischere Note.
Ich meine, wir kennen uns ja nicht persönlich.
Ihr mich schon, ich euch nicht so.
Also
Ich glaube, es gibt Momente, da hat jeder mal
sowas, woraus ich denke, ey
Wäre nice,
wenn man da, aber hält sich in
Grenzen. Bei mir liegt es aber auch mit daran,
dass mir die meisten
Leute, also die meisten anderen Menschen
so extrem auf den Sack gehen.
Ich bin froh, dass ich die paar Leute kenne,
die ich kenne und ich mich mit denen gut verstehe,
mit denen ich mich gut verstehe.
Aber mehr bräuchte ich nicht, ganz ehrlich.
Die meisten Leute
gehen mir einfach nur auf den Sack und das
oftmals durch pure Anwesenheit.
Teil 2 der Abschlussprüfung war fast 100%
Netzwerktechnik.
Das kann gut oder schlecht sein, je nachdem.
Wenn die IPv6
aufgreifende Sachen wissen, wäre ich aufgeschmissen.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an.
Das
das Homelab von Jeff.
Boah, der hat aber
der hat aber einen riesen Keller, Jeff, oder?
Der hat schon am schnaufen, der Jeff.
Warte mal, der hat eine
der hat eine USV für sein komplettes Haus.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Weil wenn das hier alles
die USV ist, Alter.
Ne, das sind nicht alles die, da steht da einfach nur
Doch! Doch!
Das ist wirklich eine fette USV fürs ganze Haus.
Ist normal
in den USA, macht man das so?
Ja gut, die haben auch öfters mal Stromausfälle.
...
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung, was ich da gerade sehe.
Hat der einfach mal paar Ersatzswitche?
...
da durchzulaufen, auf einen Blick zu sehen,
okay, passt alles. Windspeed?
Dustspeed?
Was ist denn der Unterschied?
Ping to Google, 19 Millisekunden.
Für meinen Geschmack ist es
ein bisschen wasted,
weil man könnte auf dem Panel noch
deutlich mehr anzeigen,
aber nachdem es kein Touchscreen ist, es hält sich
natürlich in Grenzen, die Möglichkeiten, die man hat,
vielleicht irgendwie schnell was zu steuern.
Letztendlich ist es aber egal, ob es für uns gut ist,
es muss für ihn passen, das sage ich ja bei jeglicher
Heimautomatisierung oder Bastellei daheim
immer, das muss individuell
passen zu dem, was man vorhat.
Man kann sich inspirieren lassen
von dem, was andere Leute gemacht haben,
aber man sollte
sich da nicht so viel aufschwätzen
oder reinreden lassen, weil es muss
eben persönlich zu dem passen, was man machen will.
Und wenn man bei Bastelprojekten
nicht weiterkommt,
dann wirst du ja immer schön ins Mikrocontroller-Forum
gehen.
Da wird einem geholfen.
Mikrocontroller.net, bestes Forum
überhaupt.
Kokona.
Das kannst du auch noch machen, wenn Strom billig ist.
Das ist kein richtiges Kokona-Home.
Boah!
Nice Beleuchtung.
Das ist zwar komplett overkill dafür,
sehr, sehr schön, sehr schön.
Ohne Mist, das ist ein,
wie geleckt.
Also echt nice.
Zwar komplett overkill wahrscheinlich
und übertrieben, aber
es sieht Rechenzentrum-Mega aus
als viele echte Rechenzentren.
This is the little lab.
We have a little monitor here
that also runs the display with some Proxmox
stats on it normally.
was hat er da wieder drehen man da den gleichen schrank wie ich zum sortieren von elektronik
kleinkram ja das lab sieht besser aus wie das wohnzimmer es ist enorm wichtig dass man led
strips in seinem rektor hat das ist das geht der performance boost leute guck mal was ist
das alte hp zeug oder von den farben her oder dell ich bringe das immer durcheinander also dass
da oben ist dell hp war früher auch so so rötlich so dl3 80 und sowas da qx dankeschön
ja mittlerweile mittlerweile sind die dinger sind die dinger grün aber früher waren die genau so was
hier hier so dieses dieses diese hier da genau so sahen die dinger früher aus ja aber gern fünf
oder so war was altes
ja genau
hp war früher so an sechsgar früher so dunkel dunkel rot braun so von erfahrungen schon nach
und gerade diese dinge die alte ibm dinge hat man immer gut erkannt und was ich bis heute nicht
verstanden habe ist bei den alten ibm dinger da war immer so ne so eine metall kugel vorne im
gehäuse so eine kleine und ich habe bis heute nicht gekämpft
die da war aber man sieht es jetzt nicht bin ich jetzt die hand oftmals früher hier vorne
in diesem gitter steckte so eine metall kugel drin ich hatte ich habe bis heute nicht gecheckt
wofür das war einfach glaube ich einfach für die optik oder
proxmox cluster was haben die wieder daheim laufen alter und guck mal wie viel storage man
alles ssds also ich gebe zu es ist super nice so was zu
machen
haben ja also der haben faktor aber was machst du denn damit ich meine selbst wie heißt der typ
der fünf kubernetes cluster daheim typ wo manchmal gucken selbst er hat ja darauf nichts laufen der
hat sachen um sein zeug zu verwalten darauf laufen und und ein dashboard oder so ja ja
genau genau tech tech und tim tech und tim ja das ja auch alles super hübsch gemacht und da aber
im endeffekt hat er auch nur management und management zu betreiben ich frag mich echt was
der da alles drauf laufen hat hier was hat alles drauf laufen alter
auf dem web heisst das ist irgendwas von ebay die dinger sehen auch schon ein bisschen älter aus oder meinte das ist ein aktueller xeon davon zwei stück und zweifel.
Zwei Stück on board.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Nur ein halbes Terabyte RAM.
Da geht aber noch was.
Schön, schön mit den Kabeln hat er das gemacht.
Finde ich nice, dass er sich auch eine Packung gekauft hat.
Mit kurzen.
Ja, Glasfaserkabel am Start.
Da hinten hat er nochmal einen Stehner.
Also ohne Scheiß, das ist rechenzentrumiger als viele Rechenzentren.
Hat sogar eine KVM, wo er sich...
Moment, Moment, wie viele Maschinen?
32 Machines?
32?
Alter!
Wow!
Oh shit!
Chat...
Monitoring Alert von der Arbeit.
MonkaS.
Habt ihr es gerade gehört im Hintergrund?
Problem.
Kritisch.
Eieiei.
Eieiei, jetzt geht's aber los hier.
Alarm!
Hört er gar nicht mehr auf, ey.
Guck mal kurz rein.
Ah, okay, der übliche Service, der immer Probleme hat.
MS-SQL-Connection-Fail.
Da bin ich raus, Leute.
Da bin ich raus.
Alter, es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Jetzt werde ich noch angerufen.
Ich muss da mal kurz drangehen.
Ah, okay.
Ich wurde nicht angerufen.
Das war nur das Monitoring-System, das gedacht hat, das hat mich nicht erreicht.
Ja, nee, MS-SQL ist nix für mich.
Das ignoriere ich jetzt.
Einfach mal.
Ich bin eh nicht im Einsatz.
Insofern kann ich's doppelt ignorieren.
Also ich hab keine Rufbereitschaft oder so am Wochenende.
Ich hab nur hier nebenbei das Handy liegen gehabt.
Deswegen hab ich mal draufgeguckt gerade.
MS-SQL-Server-Fail.
Ja, gut, nice.
Da bin ich ja zum Glück raus.
Da hab ich nix mit zu tun.
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Alter, 32 Maschinen.
Leaked, ja.
Und dann ein kleines Drawer mit dem wichtigsten, was du brauchst.
Ah, so sieht das bei mir auch aus.
Du hast nie genug Optik.
Da hat er recht.
Das Problem ist, dass 10 Gig SFP-Plus-Module viel zu teuer sind.
Ja, bei mir sind da andere Sachen drin, aber genau dieses Regal hab ich auch für sowas hier.
Das ist das, was ich euch vorhin gezeigt hab.
Oder mehr oder weniger dieses Regal.
Ich hab nicht so geschönte, geriffelte Dinger da oben.
Ich hab da so, ich hab da meine ganzen Elektronik-Sensoren und sowas drin.
So was drinne liegen.
Sag mal, seh ich das richtig, dass das Hälfte von dem Zeug, was er da hat, ist Netzwerkequipment?
Was ist denn da alles angeschlossen und was machen die da eigentlich?
Wo bekommt man dieses Regal her?
Bei Amazon.
Ja, ich hab das vorhin gezeigt.
Von, ist das der Wendler?
Nee, oder?
Nee, nee, nee.
Was macht der Wendler eigentlich?
Gibt's den noch?
Ja.
So sehr interessiert's mich auch nicht.
Es ist mir so zu sagen.
Was der macht.
Äh, Schrank oder Regal.
Hier.
Was ist das Ding?
Also ich hab nur, ich hab den unteren und den oberen Teil.
Allerdings sind es zwei unterschiedliche Schränke.
Das ist sehr...
Sehr praktisch zum Sortieren von Kleinkram.
Oh, besser nicht nach.
Nee, nee, ich hab noch nicht nachgeguckt.
So sehr interessiert's mich nicht.
Was hat der für krasses Equipment im Haus verteilt mit dem, mit dem ganzen Netzwerkzeug?
Ich mein ganz ehrlich, oh Mist.
Ich, ich, ich, ich denke, ich denke mir ja schon immer.
Ich denke mir schon immer, ich bin etwas übertrieben unterwegs hier.
Mit meinem...
So, hallo Leute.
Server Schräg, Schräg, Schräg, Schräg, Technik, Raum.
Sieht jetzt schon ein bisschen besser aus als...
Ja.
Bestes Kabelmanagement, by the way.
Ich dachte schon, ich bin da irgendwie ein bisschen...
Was gibt's denn hier sonst noch Schönes?
Also ganz hier unten...
Bisschen übertrieben unterwegs im Vergleich zu den, zu den meisten Leuten, ja.
Aber das ist ja echt mal komplett next level.
...
Aber man muss echt sagen,
ich meine, vorne sieht es
stylischer aus als hinten.
Also für das, wenn er das alles
selbst gemacht hat, da ist sehr
viel Arbeit
reingeflossen. Und ich
finde auch, dass er das sehr schick gemacht hat.
Was der Strom
bei denen kostet, ja, das würde ich auch gerne wissen.
Bist du dir sicher, dass es nur
ein Netzteil ist? Ich meine, nur weil es ein Stecker ist,
heißt es nicht, dass es nur ein Netzteil ist.
Meistens zwar schon,
aber je nachdem, was es ist, nicht unbedingt.
Das könnte durchaus
hier ein Dual-Netzteil oder so sein.
Keine Ahnung. Ich sehe das gar nicht. Wo ist das Netzteil?
Hier irgendwo. Ne, das ist
ein Dual-Netzteil hier. Guck. Ein Netzteil.
Zwei Netzteile. Ich würde sagen,
das ist ein Dual-Netzteil.
Er hat sogar gesagt, zwei.
Siehst du?
Vor allem, was das auch gekostet hat.
Alles, ey.
Prima, schöne Stromkabel.
Das ist, wo die Oomphaloopas leben.
Also, wir sind alleine.
Und, äh, das ist es.
Das zeigt euch mein
Home-Lab.
Ich würde gerne wissen,
mal gucken, ob da noch ein Video ist.
Ich würde gerne wissen, was der da drauf hat.
Okay.
Das ist der richtige Technik-Giga-Chat.
Ich sage euch, Leute.
Alle Leute, die ein teures Oszilloskop daheim haben,
da weißt du Bescheid.
Ja, was er damit macht,
würde mich auch interessieren.
Aber da gibt es...
Da gibt es anscheinend kein Video zu.
Ich habe es nur rausgehört.
Er hat halt da sein restliches...
Was geht denn da?
Mehr Cat-Content.
Also, mich interessiert halt immer,
was die Leute damit machen.
Er hat jetzt gesagt,
er hat da ein paar Kameras dran angebunden
und halt auch die anderen Räume in seinem Haus,
wo ein bisschen Technik steht.
Aber das Netzwerkequipment ist super high...
Naja, okay.
Ich musste ein bisschen relativieren.
Für den Heimbereich super high performance.
Ja, der hat zwischen den ganzen unterschiedlichen Verteilern...
Hat der 10 Gig Glasfaser liegen und alles.
Da ist halt immer die Frage,
was ist denn da dran, dass das alles braucht?
Überhaupt ist mal das, dass das ein Hobby ist.
Ja, bestimmt.
Gebastelt ist auch mein Hobby.
Aber für mich lohnt sich das preisleistungstechnisch alles nicht.
Mein Rack ist unter 100 Watt.
60 oder so.
Mit allem drin.
Ich habe eine 10 Slot Minecraft Server.
Ja, das wird es sein.
Also ich habe auch 10 Gig am Start.
Allerdings bei mir geht 10 Gig eigentlich nur bei mir ins Arbeitszimmer.
Es geht zum NAS.
Ja.
Es geht zu einem zweiten Switch,
der hier neben mir steht auf der linken Seite an meinem Basteltisch.
Und es geht...
10 Gig an meinen Desktop-Rechner.
Das war es.
Potenziell könnte 10 Gig auch noch ins Erdgeschoss und in den Keller gehen.
Da liegt ein Kabel dafür da.
Aber da habe ich nichts, was in irgendeiner Art und Weise 10 Gig bräuchte.
Weiß nicht.
Ich muss mir jetzt noch ein bisschen Cat-Content angucken.
Geht nur drei Minuten.
Do you still want to take a break?
Ach, ist das eine Modelleisenbahn?
Oh, das finden die ja super spannend, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Wenn da so was Kleines im Kreis rumsaust.
Ja.
Oh, da wäre meine drauf abgegangen.
Genauso hätte die da auch davor gesetzt.
Also, was Chico am liebsten gemacht hat...
Chico ist die hier unten.
Die hier unten rechts.
Was Chico am liebsten gemacht hat, ist...
Laserpointer fand die gar nicht mal so geil,
weil das konnte man nicht richtig fangen.
Was Chico am liebsten gemacht hat, bei solchen Spielchen, ist...
Ich habe so einen Tunnel gekauft.
Der lag im Wohnzimmer.
So einen Plastiktunnel.
Und da hat die sich teilweise hinter den Tunnel gesetzt.
Und da wusste ich, ich muss mit der jetzt, wir gucken, durch den Tunnel spielen.
Und da musste ich immer auf die andere Seite vom Tunnel und da durchgucken.
Und dann wieder weg.
Und dann wieder durchgucken.
Und da saß die dann auch auf der anderen Seite so dahinter.
So.
Es bewegt sich.
Und irgendwann musstest du aufpassen.
Irgendwann hat die von 0 auf 100 beschleunigt.
Und ist dir entgegengesprintet durch den Tunnel.
Da musstest du dann nach Möglichkeit nicht gerade dein Face davor haben.
Ich habe dann, wenn ich wusste, dass die losrennt,
habe ich meistens nur meinen Fuß immer noch davor gemacht.
Mit Socken drüber.
Dann konnte die meinen Fuß fangen.
Den Fuß davor gemacht.
Ein bisschen gewackelt.
Und dann ist die wirklich...
Katzen haben ja im Prinzip keine Beschleunigungsdauer.
Die sind von Stillstand auf Fullspeed.
Ohne Beschleunigung dazwischen.
Die sind Infinite G-Force resistent.
Habe ich so das Gefühl.
Die brauchen keine Beschleunigung.
Also Chico konnte auch von 0 zu 3 Milliarden kmh durch den Tunnel.
Du hast wirklich gesehen, Chico ist in Ruhe.
Und Chico kommt aus dem Tunnel raus.
Chico hat im Prinzip keine Beschleunigungsphase gehabt.
Und dann hat sie sich halt auf den Fuß gestürzt.
Weil der musste gefangen werden.
Bremsen funktioniert nicht so gut.
Guck dir das an.
Die hauen doch jetzt auf den Zug drauf, oder?
Ja.
Das hätte mich auch sehr gewundert, wenn der Zug nicht umgehauen wird.
Da liegt was dickes auf der Strecke.
Ne, gar nicht auf der Strecke.
Oh.
Ich habe übrigens gelesen,
dass Katzen das nicht willentlich steuern können.
Ihre Pupillen.
Das passiert alles automatisch.
Das ist ein bisschen wie bei euch.
Ihr könnt ja auch so ein bisschen...
Ihr könnt eure Pupillen auch nicht willens...
Also absichtlich steuern.
Ihr könnt jetzt auch nicht sagen,
ich mache jetzt meine Pupillen schmal oder...
Das passiert automatisch.
Mit Chico habe ich immer...
Warte mal, ich habe doch irgendwie sowas...
Wo ist denn das Video mit den Katzen?
Wo habe ich das hier?
Ich müsste mal ein Video machen.
Das ist schon jetzt zwei, drei Monate her.
Wo ist das Video mit...
Wenn einer ein Video sieht, wo Chico drauf ist,
sagt Bescheid.
Alter, wie ich mich gequält habe bei diesem Drecksvideo.
Ich habe so keinen Bock, das zu machen.
Da ist Chef für ein Jahr.
Ja.
Hallo, Leute.
So.
Das musste ich mit Chico manchmal spielen hier.
Sie lag auf dem Bett neben mir.
Und...
Dann ging das Ganze so.
Guckt euch meinen Arm an.
Ich musste schon ein paar Mal machen, ja.
Das war gefährlich.
So, und gleich hat sie keinen Bock mehr.
So Dinger musste ich mit Chico machen.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Und dann ist sie ab und zu von 0 auf 100
weggesprintet irgendwo anders hin.
Ich glaube, jetzt sprintet sie auch gleich weg.
Guck, jetzt reflektiert irgendwas.
Was ist da los?
Ja, das ist die andere.
Es war so klar, dass der Zug umgehauen werden muss.
Die sind aber niedlich, die zwei.
Okay, so Halsbänder mögen sie eigentlich gar nicht.
Aber...
Modelleisenbahn im Homelab.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Übrigens, sorry, Leute.
Falls ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen habe,
schreibt es doch mal mit Ed Wubblos.
Sollte ich was übersehen haben.
Da ist sie.
Und...
Ist das hier irgendeine japanische Modelleisenbahn-Club oder...
Oh, da unten.
Sie hat es anvisiert.
Gleich.
Oh, oh.
Chat, wisst ihr, was ich mir mal sowas...
was immer denke stellt euch mal vor ihr seid eine maus und ihr seht so was wenn
ihr aus eurem loch guckt das heißt ihr euch ganz schön in die
hose oder was in den usa sind kinderzimmer provider nicht unüblich das
könnte das nutzen des krassen hobel was sind kinderzimmer provider du meinst
dass die dass die irgendwie netzwerk für andere leute in der nachbarschaft
bereitstellen 1&1 glaube die 1&1 sieht sich zumindest selbst nicht so ich habe
tatsächlich bei 1&1 schon ganz jahrelang den server soll jonas nicht 1&1 aber das
glaube ich der gleiche laden oder oder war jonas strato
da habe ich einen 1 dollar 1 euro sorry ein 1 euro server
und der ist auch seit jahren tatsächlich ein euro eine feste ipv4 adresse was das
wertvoll sein
dem ganzen ding ist die sind aber auch niedlich die zweiter oder guck mal
jonas 1 und 1 okay das ist super krass entertainment für die katzen
ich glaube die sind happy ich bin als maus machst du dir in die
machst du machst du dir in die hose wenn du so wenn du aus seinem auge noch
guckst und siehst sowas davor sei auf die schienen kackt katzen kacken nicht
einfach random irgendwo hin das sei denn sie haben
irgendwas nicht erwischt zu lahm ich könnte aber auch gucken die zwei stellen
dir vor du wirst auf mausgröße geschrumpft was sie dann mit dir
machen würde die würde solange auf mich drauf hauen oder vielleicht auch nicht
rein beißen bis ich halb tot bin und mich da liegen lassen die zwei sind echt
niedlich
hahaha keine ahnung an das ist der verkauf der karte-portrait
dass du so lange ohne Katze aushältst.
Naja, also Chico ist im Dezember
gestorben. Das sind jetzt vier Monate.
Mal gucken. Früher oder später
hole ich mir schon wieder eine.
Ja. Okay.
Das war sehr wichtig, dass wir das
jetzt geguckt haben. Jetzt kriege ich
wahrscheinlich, dadurch, dass ich mir das angeguckt habe,
hört es wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr auf, mir sowas zu erzählen.
Was haben wir denn hier? Secret Homelab.
Okay, ich...
Moment, das ist...
Pass auf, das ist
jetzt Modelleisenbahn und
Homelab in einem.
Der YouTube-Algorithmus ist feifert.
Der YouTube-Algorithmus hat festgestellt,
Katzen, Homelab,
Modelleisenbahn
und jetzt kommt
Homelab mit Katzen und Modelleisenbahn
als nächstes.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch? Was ist das?
Most Popular Computer
Operating System 1985
bis 2024.
Die Frage
ist,
ist da Mobile drinnen?
Oder nicht?
Also meint er mit Computer, Computer, Desktop
oder halt Computer in Form von, ja,
Universal. Also,
wenn Mobile drinnen ist,
dann sieht es anders aus, als das, was ich jetzt
sagen würde. Ansonsten ist die Sache halt
relativ easy, ja.
Windows 11,
beziehungsweise, ich glaube, es ist immer noch
Windows 10, ne? Windows 10
gefolgt von Windows 11,
Mac
und irgendwann, oder vielleicht dazwischen
noch ein paar andere Windows-Versionen.
Und irgendwo
Linux.
Aber wir sind uns ja einig,
2024 wird das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Eindeutig.
Das, Alter.
Gut, dass Unix sinkt
und DOS steigt,
liegt auch daran, dass
Heimcomputer sich immer
mehr etablieren.
Ich meine, hier noch nicht
so extrem, aber das
kommt dann so die nächsten 10 Jahre,
geht es ja richtig krass durch die,
weckelt. 96 hat gefühlt
fast jeder Zweite so irgendwie
einen daheim und 86 war das schon
auch ein bisschen,
ja, ein bisschen was Seltenes.
Aber davor waren das ja
alles irgendwelche
Uni-Ausstattung, Großrechner
oder sonst wie.
Was ist VMS?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Latest Release
3 Months Ago.
Ein Maskottchen haben sie schon mal.
Gucken wir mal, wie das 2023 aussieht.
Es sieht aus, ein bisschen aus wie eine IBM
Host Konsole, so supermoderner Shit.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Bis jetzt DOS 4.0 ist Open Source.
Aha, weil ich jetzt gar nicht,
ob das irgendwie eine Bedeutung hat in der heutigen Zeit,
dass das irgendjemand was bringt.
Man kann sich angucken.
Ja, so eher aus historischen Gründen.
Irgendwann kommt dann auch noch mal Amiga.
Ach nee, Amiga ist schon hier am Start.
Ja,
OS 2.
Ja, da hat sich IBM auch leicht verkalkuliert.
Und OS 2 ist schon wieder weg.
Nee, da ist es.
Oh, jetzt wird es langsam Zeit für Windows.
Jawoll, da ist es.
Ja, die nächsten Jahre wird Windows
extrem, super heftig an DOS dann vorbeiziehen.
Wobei ich weiß nicht, wie sie es rechnen.
Man muss ja dazu sagen, dass jeder Windows 3, 3, 11, 3, 1,
wie auch immer rechnet, der hat ja noch ein DOS drunter.
Wo glaubst du haben die solche Daten her?
Das steht meistens hier unten drunter.
Also das kommt garantiert.
Data is beautiful subreddit, hätte ich jetzt vermutet.
Und da kann man eigentlich immer gucken, wo die das herhaben.
Set counter.
Ja, mein aktuell steigt DOS und Windows, weil DOS Voraussetzung ist für Windows.
Also kann so noch Windows gar nicht an DOS vorbeiziehen.
Windows NT, Mac.
Mac ist halt bei den Amis auch saubeliebt.
Wird man glaube ich. Also.
Ja, jetzt.
Jetzt vorbei.
Windows 95 war tatsächlich ein riesengroßer Wurf für die damals.
Das ging so durch die Decke.
Aber das stimmt nicht, Windows 95 hatte auch noch DOS als Unterbau.
Also das passt ja so gar nicht richtig.
Dann das ist innerhalb von ein paar Jahren.
Das ging einfach durch die Decke.
Ja, okay.
Die zählen Windows 95 nur als Windows und nicht als DOS und Windows.
OS 2 ist halt einfach wieder weg.
Ja gut, jetzt sehen wir ein paar Windows Version.
Die sich abwechseln.
Jetzt gibt es jetzt gleich gibt es mal ganz kurzen Spike, Windows ME und dann ist dann auch relativ schnell wieder weg.
Der Spike glaub ich noch nicht mal Windows ME.
Der taucht erst mal gar nicht auf.
Jetzt müsste mal Windows 2000 kommen.
Windows 2000 ist ja quasi so der eigentliche Vorgänger von dem, was wir heute verwenden.
Ja, Windows 2000.
Das macht YouTube automatisch, wenn ich Pause drücke.
XP wird lange da bleiben.
Dann kommt man mal kurz Windows 7, was auch ganz gut abgeht.
Aber Windows 8 wird's dann verkackten.
Alter was wird denn da Musik los jetzt?
Ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, Windows XP war das beste Windows.
Jetzt nicht so in der Form, dass ich das heute noch verwenden wollen würde.
Aber Windows XP war das letzte Windows,
was irgendwie aus einem Guss
erschien
danach war es Gefrickel as fuck
ich fand da auch
Windows XP hatte
was eigenes, das war so eine
so ein bisschen Comic-hafte Oberfläche
heute sieht das so
so kühl
und zu clean aus
ich weiß nicht, ob Mobile
dazu kommt
2007 wissen wir es
2007 geht der ganze Smartphone-Krempel
so richtig los
aber ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass
Mobile dabei ist
Computer Operating System, willst du sagen, dass
dein Smartphone kein Computer ist?
Windows XP
Linux Giga Chat Time
weil wenn es auch
Server mit einbezieht
was es anscheinend nicht
wirklich macht hier
sondern nur Desktop
Computer
dann müsste Linux jetzt tatsächlich langsam
anfangen, durch die Decke zu gehen
das Internet läuft auf Linux
mal
übertrieben gesagt
und es kommt bei Windows 7 irgendwann
ach nee sorry, sorry
Vista
ich hab's ja ganz vergessen, wir hatten ja erst noch Vista
ah ja jetzt Windows 7, Windows 7 geht gut ab
ob das damit zusammenhängt, dass Linux mal kurz ein bisschen
hoch und jetzt runter geht? Weil das bei Windows Vista so schön dort ist.
so schlecht ankam.
Aber so 2007 rum gab es mit
Ubuntu und Compits
auch eine richtig coole Oberfläche.
Also Ubuntu, das war damals
noch ein Gnome Desktop. Gnome mit
Compits unter Ubuntu, das war
aus meiner Sicht, aus meiner Sicht war das
Peak, Peak Linux Desktop.
Der damalige,
die damalige Gnome
Version plus Compits
und dass Ubuntu halt einfach so ein Ding war, was
ja gut
funktioniert hat.
Das war Peak Linux Desktop aus meiner Sicht.
Gerade Compits.
Compits war so nice
und war so der Hingucker,
was
sonst keiner einfach hatte.
Ausbildung 2007.
Windows 7, ja.
Geht rauf. Ja, Windows
8 wollte ja keiner haben.
Guck mal, immer wenn
eine neue scheiß Windows Version rauskommt,
geht die Linux Verbreitung
hoch. Ne, Ubuntu
mag ich heute gar nicht mehr.
Noch nicht mal mehr auf dem Server.
Ich war lange Zeit mal Windows, äh, ähm,
Windows Server, ja ganz bestimmt. Ähm,
lange Zeit Ubuntu Server Fan.
Aber da bin ich auch wieder weg von.
Kommt Debian und fertig.
Debian only.
Und auf dem Desktop Arch,
by the way.
Warum ist MS-DOS
vor macOS? Legacy-Zeug.
Hier oben ist ja immer noch OSX.
Okay, Windows 10.
Windows 10 wird das natürlich auch
ein bisschen brauchen, aber dann,
auf Platz 1 landen am Ende.
Linux legt auch wieder ein bisschen zu.
Ich meine, streng genommen
ist Linux schon Unix-like, ne.
Wo ist Windows 9 geblieben?
Das weiß nur Microsoft.
Ich glaube, ich glaube
tatsächlich, dass Linux mit ein bisschen mehr,
als es jetzt ist, enden wird, hier bei
2023. Aber ich
meine, es wird sein, letztendlich
Windows 10 vorne, gefolgt
von Windows 11, denke
ich mal. Und
dann Mac und dann,
Linux. Eventuell noch ein paar Windows-Versionen,
ein paar Mac-Versionen zwischen Linux.
Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht,
bis wann die Daten gehen. Vielleicht ist
Windows 11 auch gar nicht so weit oben mit dabei.
Ja, Chrome OS kann auch
wieder verschwinden.
Wobei man fairnesshalber sagen muss, dass
Browser heute
eigentlich schon als eigenes Betriebssystem
durchgehen.
Und angeblich, man weiß es ja
nicht genau, angeblich
hat Chrome mittlerweile
fünfmal mehr Source-Codes,
als Windows 11.
Habe ich gelesen.
Man kann es nicht wirklich nachvollziehen, ob das stimmt.
Aber ich kann es mir schon vorstellen.
DOS, klar, beispielsweise
auf alten Geldautomaten und sowas.
Okay, im Prinzip ist es so, wie ich mir das
gedacht habe. Leute, genau das
habe ich vorausgesagt, oder? Genau
das habe ich gesagt. Windows 10,
gefolgt von Windows 11, gefolgt von Mac,
gefolgt von Linux. Wobei ich ja persönlich
vermutet hätte, dass auch ein paar
Windows-Versionen zwischen Linux und dem Kram hier liegen.
Aber, ja.
Was heißt,
was heißt, was ich vorausgesagt habe?
Ist ja Blödsinn. Ist ja nicht so, als müsste...
Ich sehe das ja aktuell. Es ist nichts, was
ich jetzt predicted hätte, sondern anhand
dessen, wie es sich halt aktuell aussieht,
habe ich gesagt, so müsste
es sein. Ja.
Ja, so hätte ich das auch
vermutet. Interessant wäre,
ob es das Ganze noch für Server-Betriebssysteme
gibt. Linux hat sich in den letzten
zwei Jahren verdoppelt. Ja, das hängt immer
ein bisschen auch ab, wie die Quellen
das zählen und so. Aber kann ich mir schon vorstellen,
wie die Quellen
viele Leute sind ja schon ein bisschen pisst
und durch die Initiative, gerade was
was Valve angeht und Steam und
Games und
auch die Möglichkeit,
was gerade
Videobearbeitung sowas angeht
und auch Sachen
wie Blender und so, dass es ja immer
etablierter ist alles.
Das hat schon dazu beigetragen, dass viele Leute
Linux
mehr verwenden.
Ich meine, ich verwende auch Linux
täglich.
Je nachdem, was ich mache,
mehr als Windows.
Wenn man die Arbeit weglässt. Ja, auf der Arbeit ist
es halt Windows
und Linux halt auch, aber
da verdiene ich halt mein Geld letztendlich
mit Linux. Aber ich muss immer
noch so einen hässlichen Windows-Laptop benutzen,
den ich zum
Glück eigentlich nur als
VPN-Endpunkt brauche.
Ja. Habe ich jetzt eigentlich
Package-Updates gemacht heute?
Ja, oder?
Ne, doch. Arch, by the way.
Ich hatte doch heute Morgen schon Package-Updates
gemacht, oder?
Aber Arch Linux hat natürlich schon wieder neue Package-Updates.
Es ist halt, und das
sage ich jetzt so objektiv,
wie es geht, deswegen sage ich auch aus
meiner Sicht, ja,
wenn man gerne bastelt
und
Software entwickelt, das nicht
jetzt irgendwie exklusiv Windows ist,
es führt kein Weg
daran vorbei, entweder Linux zu benutzen
oder
meinetwegen eine Mac OS.
Mac OS ist Linux
beziehungsweise Unix-artig genug.
Ist ja im Kern ein BSD.
Free BSD.
Und
da ist Windows
not even close. Allein
schon, dass man hier ein ordentliches
Terminal und eine ordentliche Shell hat
und ein System, was sich auch
so anfühlt, als ist es dafür gedacht,
so benutzt zu werden.
Selbst WSL kommt
da nicht ran. Mit WSL hast du immer
so kleinen Scheiß, der dir auf den Sack geht.
Visual Studio-Enjoyer.
Aber wozu braucht man noch Visual Studio?
Visual Studio brauchst du doch für nichts mehr.
Visual Studio brauchst du vielleicht, wenn du
Windows-only für Windows-Programme unterwegs bist,
aber selbst da
würde ich unter Windows mittlerweile
hauptsächlich Rider benutzen für .NET-Entwicklung
oder irgendwelche
anderen JetBrains-Kram
für die üblichen größeren
größeren Sprachen.
Wenn jetzt einer
sagen wir, was auch immer
Java macht,
IntelliJ oder so.
Wie ist Code und Rider unterstützen
nicht alles, was Visual Studio unterstützt?
Das mag sein, aber was
Relevantes unterstützen die denn nicht?
Wenn wir mal von Windows-only
Sachen ausgehen, wo du eh am besten
unter Windows.
Service Fabric, okay.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was Service Fabric ist, aber wenn
es das nicht unterstützt.
Azure Service Fabric. Ja.
Das ist vielleicht sogar gut,
dass sie das nicht unterstützen.
Warum muss Visual Studio das unterstützen?
Warum braucht Visual Studio
eine Unterstützung für die
Kubernetes-Geschichte von Microsoft?
Man baut in der IDE seine
Software und
am Ende hast du dann vielleicht irgendeinen
Terraform,
was dir den Kram aufbaut und
das brauchst du keine IDE-Unterstützung.
Also
ich brauch's nicht
und ich mach gerne was in .NET.
Was trinken jetzt?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Alter!
Was war das jetzt?
Ich übersetz...
What the hell?
Ey!
Das ist so ein typischer Fall von
Warum macht man die Bedienung aufm Desktop so kacke?
Oh, ich hab grade ne Scam.
Ne Scam-SMS bekommen.
Sehr geehrter Kunde,
für den Versand Ihrer Sendung fallen
Zollgebühren an.
Weitere Details finden Sie hier.
Okay, Spam melden.
Spam
löschen und melden.
Klingt legit, ja.
Ehrlich.
Passiv akzeptiert.
Nach meiner Recherche...
Man kann das immer
gut, man kann da immer was Böswilliges
reininterpretieren, ja.
Nach meiner Recherche
heißt, also wenn die Leute da schreiben,
heißt das meistens so viel wie
Ich hab nachgeguckt
und ich hab voll den Durchblick
und ich bin vor allem
und das Konzert hat das nicht geschrieben
und ich bin vor allem zu einem anderen Schluss
gekommen als du.
Ich habe mich informiert, ich habe recht
und du liegst falsch und ich zeige dir jetzt,
warum du falsch liegst. Du Vollidiot.
Wie können wir so etwas in Zukunft verhindern?
Das bedeutet so viel wie mach das nie wieder.
Das würde ich nicht so sehen.
Das sehe ich nicht so.
Es kommt immer drauf an,
in welchem
Rahmen
das fällt, aber sagen wir mal,
wenn das jetzt, wahrgenommen es ist
wirklich was kaputt gegangen
und man sitzt da mit irgendwie
zehn Leuten zusammen und das Thema ist,
wie können wir sowas in Zukunft verhindern,
würde ich das nicht passiv-aggressiv
gegen mich deuten.
Wenn es natürlich einer exklusiv
nur an mich schreibt, okay,
vielleicht.
Aber es kann mich ja auch jemand fragen,
zu was, wo ich nichts mitzuteile.
Also kommt auf den Kontext an.
Und es wirkt so, als würde der Verfasser dir helfen wollen
bei deinem Problem, aber das will er nicht.
Mach es einfach nie wieder.
Mein Chef ist jetzt in CC.
Okay, mein Chef ist jetzt in CC bedeutet,
leck mich, ich habe keinen Bock mehr mit dir rum
zu zackern hier, rum zu diskutieren.
Bam, ich habe jetzt meinen Chef in CC.
Das ist eine offizielle Kriegserklärung.
In dem Fall solltest du schnell nachlegen
und ebenfalls Leute in CC nehmen.
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Am besten einfach Gesamt-IT in CC.
... hat gewonnen. Ich habe es auf dem Schirm.
Das bedeutet so viel wie, hör auf mich ständig an...
Ich habe es auf dem Schirm.
Das ist so viel wie, da sind wir dran.
Chef, seid ihr da auch immer dran?
Da sind wir dran. Ich nehme das mit.
Ich nehme das mit.
Wir sind dran.
... als wäre ich ein kleines Kind und lass mich in Ruhe.
Ich werde es aber trotzdem vergessen. Wahrscheinlich.
Gibt es schon etwas Neues?
Das bedeutet so viel wie, warum brauchst du so lange?
Ich habe dir schon vor fünf Tagen geschrieben.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ich frage das auch schon.
Ich frage dann so etwas wie, hast du schon etwas Neues gehört?
Das ist nicht unbedingt, weil ich will,
dass die Leute das jetzt irgendwie mehr machen
als etwas anderes.
Oftmals einfach nur, weil ich wissen will,
ob jemand anderes dann schon darauf reagiert hat.
Das ist ja oftmals auch wieder abhängig
von irgendjemand.
Das sehe ich gar nicht so.
Kommt natürlich immer ein bisschen auf den Kontext an.
Wie bei vielen Sachen, der Kontext macht...
Wie bereits erwähnt,
bedeutet so viel wie, du Vollidiot,
habe ich scheinbar nicht verstanden,
weil du dumm bist oder nicht lesen kannst.
Also lass es mich nochmal wiederholen,
damit auch du es verstehst.
Korrigiere mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Das bedeutet so viel wie, ich liege definitiv nicht falsch,
aber ich will höflich klingen.
Das sage ich aber tatsächlich auch öfters.
Korrigiere mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Wobei ich das tatsächlich so meine.
Vielleicht kommt das auch nicht so an.
Also gerade wenn ich von einem Thema
jetzt nicht primär so die Ahnung habe
oder teilweise gar nicht dabei gewesen bin,
korrigiert mich.
Ich war da nicht dabei, aber ich habe gehört,
das finde ich gar nicht so schlimm.
Also den meisten Sachen stimme ich aber zu.
Okay, dann gucken wir nochmal,
was Robert
in seinem Secret Homelab hat.
Ist das 40 Gig QSFP?
Oder was sehe ich da, Chatge?
Wer kennt sich damit auch aus?
Oder noch aus?
Wer kennt sich damit noch aus?
Gut, ich kann wieder keinen Satz bilden, Alter.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Das ist ein SAS Anschluss, das ist kein QSFP.
Senior IT Experte, by the way.
Okay, IT, das kenne ich.
Das sind so,
das sind für die SAS Controller
beziehungsweise für RAID Controller
sind das so verschiedene Firmwares, die es gibt.
Je nachdem, wie die,
wie das Betriebssystem die Platten präsentiert
kriegt, also quasi direkt durchgemappt
oder eben nur das, was auf dem,
auf der Karte angelegt ist und sowas.
Ich glaube, IT Mode ist das, wenn du willst,
dass das OS die Platten
sieht, wie wenn sie quasi auch
sagen wir mal per SATA
direkt angestöpselt wären, ohne irgendwelche
Logik noch vom Controller.
Da macht im Prinzip der Controller wirklich nur
das physische Attachen
und Adressieren.
Also keine Hardware RAID.
You ever messed about with this stuff before?
This is FFF ehh... Connectors.
Acht E-A.
They look like little duck beaks.
SAS also works.
Ja,ja,ja, so einen hatte ich in der, in der alten
Kiste auch drinne. Ja.
Nee, das war mini, so ein mini SAS
Connector hatte ich da.
So without Extenders this little
card can handle 8 Hard Drives.
It could be really expensive
feeding these Tentacle Monsters.
Ist das ein Schwede? Irgendwie war das ein Finne.
Hört sich eben so ein bisschen skandinavisch an.
...of the Exos Drives.
18 Terabyte each.
Enterprise Discs are usually a bit
cheaper than the NAS Drives
and more reliable, but they are a bit
louder and lack some features.
Auf das Case
hätte ich... Das ist ein Fractal Design
R5 oder sowas, hä?
Das Case.
Übrigens, ich mag sein Hemd
Joyce. So Dinge habe ich auch gerne an.
Ich persönlich
bin ein großer Fan
von
...wie heißt das auf Deutsch? Wechselrahmen?
Wobei das
hier irgendwo auch geht, wenn man nur die Seite
vom Gehäuse abmachen muss, ja?
Aber ich mag so Wechselrahmen.
Am besten vorne in der Front,
wo du dann solche Trays hast
zum rein und raus schieben,
die halt auch eine Backplane haben,
die hot-swappable ist.
Weil das eventuell... Also hier ist halt keine...
Hier musst du halt beide Seiten aufmachen,
dass du die Platte ordentlich rausbekommst.
Und was auch schwierig ist in dem Fall,
zu erkennen, wenn eine Platte
kaputt ist, welche Platte kaputt ist.
Das heißt, eigentlich musst du dir
ein Mapping bauen, weil
im Betriebssystem siehst du ja dann
vielleicht der Port, der kaputt ist
oder vielleicht
hast du noch
so eine Sache mit
Seriennummer oder so, die du dann noch siehst.
Es ist immer schwierig, das
zuzuordnen, wenn du in deinem
Betriebssystem siehst, Platte,
da steht dann so, SDF ist kaputt.
Ja, okay. Nice.
Welche ist SDF?
Das ist ja nicht so unbedingt von unten nach oben
immer. Also oftmals ist es halt gut,
man braucht irgendein Mapping.
Linux hat ja mehrere Möglichkeiten,
wie du eine Platte ansprechen kannst.
Sollte man vielleicht auch mal zeigen.
Du hast sowas wie
def...
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, by ID.
Disk. Genau.
Du hast Disk by ID, Disk by Label,
Disk by Path.
Da hast du manchmal die Chance, noch ein bisschen was raus zu
erkennen, welche kaputt ist.
Und dann siehst du oftmals auch in deinem Kernel-Log
drinnen.
Aber die Zuordnung, welche der Platten hier,
ist dann gar nicht so einfach.
Da bleibt dir oftmals bloß übrig,
zum Beispiel hier eine ID draufzuschreiben,
mit so einem dicken Edding.
Oder irgendwie die zu merken,
okay, welche Seriennummer, wo dran ist.
Das ist halt das Coole an so
NAS-Cases mit LEDs an den Wänden.
Wobei es dann, wenn du nicht das
vom Hersteller vorgesehene verwendest,
wobei es dann, wenn du nicht das vom Hersteller vorgesehene verwendest,
es auch sehr schwierig ist,
die Kommunikation zwischen deinem PC
und dem Wechselrahmen
und für LEDs.
Das geht über ein Protokoll, das nennt sich
SGPIO.
Das ist für solche Festplatten,
Trays und Backplanes
gedacht. Da kann man dann
signalisieren, welche Platte kaputt ist.
Die heißt Synology. Synology kann das halt,
weil das alles von einem Hersteller kommt.
Das ist schwarze Magie, Leute.
Das ist echt schwarze Magie.
Ich hab mich damit mal ein bisschen beschäftigt,
das ist aber echt komplett für den Arsch.
Und das ist so für den Arsch, dass ich sagen würde,
es ist für ein Eigenbausystem
gar nicht so
ohne weiteres möglich,
die Wechselrahmen
gescheit mit LEDs anzusteuern.
Da ist es sicherlich
einfacher, man baut sich selbst was,
mit irgendeinem Microcontroller,
der per USB dranhängt
und irgendwie einem Skript, was das dann checkt,
was ist kaputt, welche Seriennummer war das,
wo ist die drin?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da mittlerweile was besseres gibt.
Also das ist halt immer schwierig,
was ich sagen will, es ist oftmals schwierig,
festzustellen, welche Platte wirklich hiervon
jetzt kaputt ist, nach einer Meldung von deinem OS.
Ja, Seriennummer zu Ports, das ist das einzige,
was du machen kannst.
Das ist ein Computer, der etwas macht.
Kabelmanagement, das war
unglaublich zufrieden mit Kabelmanagement.
Übrigens,
warum ist das hier ein Homelab, das ist ein Rechner.
Bit stiff power cable straps.
Warum steht bei dir in der URL
immer eine 1, wenn sie markiert ist?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen
1 im Chat, da versuche ich das
zu erklären.
Oh nein, alles ist voll.
Was soll ich tun?
Du monges Kockes.
98 Terabytes.
Fucking hell.
That's a lot of space.
Dammit, it's not 100 Terabytes though.
Two drives are lost to parity.
So almost.
Two drives lost to parity?
Ist das in RAID 6?
Dann. Aber mit wieviel Platten?
Wobei, es sind gar nicht so
viele Platten. Das sind wahrscheinlich
einfach 12 oder 14 Terabyte.
Was für Platten hat er da drinnen?
Steiner, danke schön für den Sub.
18.
8 mal 18.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Ja, mit 8 Platten
kann man auch in RAID 6 machen.
Ich vermute mal,
RAID 6 ist das erste, was mir einfällt
für Parity.
Mit 2 Platten.
Also RAID 5 würde ich definitiv nicht
über 8 oder gar 12 Platten machen.
Da möchtest du eigentlich
Datenverlust haben mit einem RAID 5.
Also der Datenverlust ist
wahrscheinlicher mit einem RAID 5.
In dem Fall wie bei einem...
Ja, also...
Es ist wahrscheinlicher, dass was kaputt geht, als dass was nicht kaputt geht.
Almost.
A lot of terrible, terrible
things have happened in my closet.
It's the perfect home for my monster.
That's right.
We're also stuffing my closet.
I've always wanted to
install a little server rack somewhere.
Ja, gute Idee.
Prep work.
Lass den da, ich will jetzt einfach...
When I started this project,
it was impossible to find some plywood.
How can we be
out of plywood?
I used some oak shelf units.
It worked out fine.
The best way to keep the monster...
Das allerwichtigste
LED-Strips.
...is to put lead strips inside of your closet.
Logisch, also
ohne LED-Beleuchtung ist es unmöglich
so einen Server Rack zu betreiben mittlerweile.
I should almost do this in my
other closet, when I'm picking
out my clothing. Cool.
Gonna put a power brick in
first, to power all
the devices we're gonna put in here.
The first thing we are
going to need is organization.
So here we have
a keystone patch panel.
Glücklicherweise
benutzen immer mehr Leute
Keystone-Patch-Panels.
Es sind ja gar keine Patch-Panels.
Kommt drauf an, was du damit machst.
Aber zum Glücklicherweise benutzen immer
mehr Leute Keystone-Panels.
Habe ich auch. Ist super.
Freuen mich ja in fünf Spielen an.
Ich glaube, ich habe
sogar genau exakt das gleiche.
Das ist das Gute,
ich habe es letztes Mal schon gesagt,
das Gute an diesen Keystone-Panels ist,
dass es da verschiedene Einsätze gibt.
Du kriegst nicht nur Netzwerkstecker-Einsätze,
sondern du kriegst auch
für LC-Stecker,
das glaube ich, für Glasfaser,
für USB,
es gibt
HDMI, genau. Es gibt
Keystone quasi für nahezu alle Sachen.
Da kann man quasi auch, wenn man
was anderes mal ein bisschen durchs Rack
ziehen muss, als Netzwerkkabel,
ist das sehr praktisch.
Und die Netzwerkstecker gibt es halt auch
als
vorne und hinten in RJ45
oder nur vorne in RJ45,
hinten zum
Selbstpatchen.
Da gibt es auch die
guten Sachen zum
Keystone. Da gibt es
die mit dieser Klemme hinten.
Ja, genau, die da.
Die sind sehr nice.
Da kann man, da ist so eine
Einführhilfe dabei, hier sowas.
Da macht man das rein. Gibt es auch in verschiedenen
Ausprägungen. Aber da ist das
Patchen von den Kabeln relativ
easy.
Da packst du die Kabel so rein,
steckst das hier rein. Das da oben sind
kleine Klingen, die man da sieht. Hier, da,
guck da.
Das sind so kleine Klingen. Da schiebt man das
rein. Und durch das zuklappen
dieses
Kopfes hier, da,
drückt sich das
dann hier quasi richtig,
richtig in die Messer rein und patcht
die Kabel sich selbst.
Das ist viel einfacher als mit
kollege Werkzeug irgendwas auf Patchpanels
klemmen und so. Ja. Also
das ist, das ist nice. Und da hinten
kannst du einen Kabelbinder drum machen noch.
Find das, find das gut.
Lohnt sich das für 10 cm Glasfaser?
Nö. 10 cm Glasfaser
heißt ja im Endeffekt, du musst auf kein Patchpanel,
du gehst von einer Kiste auf die andere Kiste und gut ist.
Das lohnt sich,
das lohnt sich zum Beispiel, wenn du von
einer Kiste Glasfaser da drauf patchst
und dahinter dann quasi im Rack quasi
innen drinne.
Boah, war niesen, ne. Vom Rack
hinten beispielsweise weiter gehst
irgendwo auf
ja, auf den Kabelkanal, wo es dann
in die Decke reingeht und so.
Genau. Und außerdem,
das ist richtig, 10 cm
nimmst du ein Direct Attached Kabel und kein
Glasfaserkabel.
Ich würde eh prinzipiell für alles ein
Direct Attached Kabel nehmen, wo es die Länge hergibt.
Ist einfach,
einfach eine Handhabung, geht nicht
so schnell kaputt und ist viel billiger,
weil du keine zwei Module brauchst.
Die Seite mache ich ja auch
nicht selbst, ich würde nur die andere Seite selbst machen.
Es gibt auch
zwei Standards für Netzwerkstecker.
Ah, da bin ich so ordentlich
die Knipex-Zange.
Die ja offiziell Knipex heißen,
aber jeder sagt Knipex.
Also selbst Netzwerkkabel patchen habe ich
letztens erstmal wieder just for fun gemacht
mit einem. Es ist kacke.
Ich würde nie diese Seite
selbst patchen.
Sondern nur die andere in so ein
Keystone-Teil rein, wenn es sein muss.
Oder wenn ich schon Kabel habe,
die auf beiden Seiten einfach
fertig ist und ich das aus...
Dann nehme ich einfach
einen Keystone mit beiden Seiten RJ45.
Also es macht eigentlich
keinen Sinn, das abzuschneiden.
Außer, ja, warum auch immer.
Warum habe ich das letztens...
Moment, lass mal überlegen. Was war der Grund?
Ah ja, ich weiß, was der Grund war.
Ich weiß, was der Grund war, warum ich das
auf einen eigenen Keystone...
Keystone RJ45
Ding gepatcht habe.
Weil es ein Kabel war. Ohne Stecker dran.
Und dann hatte ich die Wahl.
Ich krimp mir so einen eigenen
Netzwerkstecker drauf.
Oder ich
mache mir so ein Keystone-Ding drauf
und mache das dann in eine Dose.
Und dann habe ich ein
Keystone-Ding drauf gemacht und eine Dose.
Das sieht man übrigens bei mir auch hier oben.
Hoffe ich.
Äh, lass mal das...
Ja, ja, hier.
...
aus der wand und da habe ich halt so ein ding drauf drauf gefehlt aber die seite
würde ich nie selbst machen wenn da schon was drauf ist was du mit einem
server raum da steht noch da habe ich mein werkzeug drin
da habe ich mal ein bisschen älter ist übrigens auch neuer schrank oben drauf
hier das ist der mit den großen daumen ist jetzt noch einer drauf mit zu
kleinen dingen zu kleinen fächern da habe ich mein elektronik sensor kram
drinne sortiert wobei ich das im ganzen haus mehr oder weniger verteilt
hier ist der kleinkram drinne werkzeugstelle 3d drucker und unten
drunter wobei das nicht mehr aktuell ist unten drunter gibt es dann halt ja da
war ich gerade am umbauen gibt es ein 10 gigabit switch
ich müsste echt mal wieder ein update video machen das sieht schon wieder
anders aus guck hier sieht man auch bei den keystone panels hier sieht man es
guck hier ist ein lc stecker drin für glasfaser kram zum keystone
ding
unten unten ein usb ist genau das gleiche hier switch ist da drinne dann
haben wir die unifile sachen sind mittlerweile auch rausgeflogen
ja ich müsste echt mal wieder updaten guck mal hatte ich da noch dicke arme
mittlerweile wie ich habe ohne scheiß zu dem zeitpunkt wie jetzt 20 kilo
abgenommen meine hände sind nicht mehr so die server kiste diese 2 ae kiste die
selbst zusammen gestrickt habe diese auch rausgeflogen ist mittlerweile ein
hp micro server hier liegt ein mikro tic 10 gigabit switch noch um letztendlich
ist da ein hp micro server drinne ruhen router eine fritz box ein kabel modem 10
gigabit switch und ein bisschen poe für die zwei access points fertig wieso
hast du kein unified mehr weil unify ewig gebraucht hat ein feature bereit zu
stellen was viele andere hersteller schon lange haben und ich immer keinen
bock mehr auf unify hatte deswegen aber die apps hast du noch von unify habe ich
nicht ich habe ruckus apps mittlerweile rockies wieder ami sagen würde
allerdings nicht die allerneuesten weil 1000 euro für den access point ist mir
dann auch ein bisschen viel ich habe gebrauchte ich habe die eine
oder eineinhalb generationen älteren ich habe so ein
aktuelle zwei nicht 12 wieder habe ich aktuell zwei
stück eine hängt drüben im wohnzimmer über poe dran und einer hängt im keller
über poe dran braucht man dafür ein extra wlan controller
nein das übernimmt ein access point mit da muss man dann die unleashed
firmware heißt das aufpacken und dann ist gut was macht otto
normalmensch mit einem home server kommt drauf an was der für
anwendungszwecke hat was du was der braucht also mein eines der
naheliegendsten sachen ist sicherlich netzwerkspeicher das hat wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich die meisten leute die an sowas denken denken ein netzwerkspeicher
ich habe da beispielsweise noch mal ein ganzes home automation sache drauf
laufen ich habe noch ein zabbix drauflaufen
tatsächlich habe ich ja privat ein zabbix laufen zabbix drauflaufen der festplatten auslastung überwacht beispielsweise
unter anderem von raspberry pi und der check of services up down sind der auch
einmal nachts so einen internet speed test macht und in die history schreibt
ansonsten läuft dann noch die software für meine
überwachungskameras drauf und ein paar kleine sachen laufen dann auch
drauf ja so ein organisationstool für meine ganzen bastelsachen wo was liegt
es ist hauptsächlich tatsächlich netzwerkspeicher und ein smart home was
da drauf läuft das ist die hauptsächliche sache und
bestimmt noch das eine oder andere was einfach funktioniert und ich jetzt schon
wieder vergessen habe manche sachen habe ich auch wieder rausgeschmissen
also ich habe beispielsweise kein payroll mehr und auch kein ad
wer ist das andere adguard home
anstatt ich habe auch kein plex oder sonst was was manche leute für
video streaming machen sehe ich keinen sinn drin
ja es hält sich in grenzen ich habe halt das drauf was ich was ich ja ich habe
tatsächlich noch eine nextcloud auch wenn ich überhaupt kein nextcloud fan
bin die verwende ich allerdings rein als
kall darf und kart darf server für kontakte und eigentlich auch eher noch
aus historischen gründen die eigentlich will ich den gar nicht mehr
haben ich wie gesagt ich mag nextcloud nicht sonderlich dann macht das ding noch
zertifikate reverse proxy für alle anderen services die ich im haus habe die
auch beispielsweise auf raspberry pi also alle alle web services bei mir haben
ja ein gültiges zertifikat über letzten crypt und da läuft der läuft auch drauf
sind eigentlich also die wichtigsten drei sachen sind tatsächlich smart home
netzwerk storage und überwachungskameras ich glaube das war es zum größten teil
was nimmst du als alternative für nextcloud naja ich verwende ja von nextcloud
nichts außer kalla von da könnte man auch der eigene eigenen kalt auf server
verwenden was da nicht gibt aber es nicht alles gibt bei fliehkagen gibt es
dann noch und buch gibt ein paar aber ich werde jetzt als nextcloud lassen weil
ich habe sich auch schon ewig nicht mehr geupdatet
ich sage wie gesagt es macht nichts was aus ein bisschen kontakte und kalender
aber ich habe kein bock auf nextcloud mehr also wenn ich da wieder mal ein
bisschen was dran rumbauen dann fliegt es raus und vielleicht lasse ich dann auch ganz neue server für nexcloud machenl discermover
Vielleicht benutze ich tatsächlich irgendeinen Cloud-Service
und importiere meine Kontakte da.
Ich weiß es noch nicht, keine Ahnung.
Weil ich ja eigentlich sowas nicht gerne mache.
Und die anderen Sachen, die ich so brauche,
die laufen tatsächlich ein bisschen dezentral.
Nicht mehr auf dem Heim-Server.
Also läuft keine Firewall-Geschichte mehr drauf.
Internet-Zugang geht da auch nicht mehr drüber.
Fernsehaufzeichnungen und sowas mit TV-Karte
läuft da auch nicht mehr drüber.
Aber das ist einfach viel zu viel Single-Point-of-Failure.
Ich habe das mittlerweile mehr aufgesplittet.
Also Raspberry Pi im Keller für die Heizung
und für die Tür-Gegen-Sprechanlage im Wohnzimmer.
So eine Linux-Kiste für Fernsehkram,
die dann quasi streamt an Shield-TV und so Sachen.
Ich habe das in einem der letzten Streams ja mal aufgemalt.
Aber jetzt mal fertig gucken.
Alter!
Diesen Karten...
Diesen Kabel-Tester, den hat jeder, oder?
Das ist glaube ich der 0815 China-Chinesen-Kabel-Tester,
den jeder irgendwann mal irgendwie in der Hand hatte.
Sag mal, wie viele von euch haben bzw. hatten diesen Kabel-Tester schon mal in der Hand?
Das ist so der billigste Einstiegskabel-Tester ever.
Jeder!
Genau dieses Teil, ey.
Die Dinger sind übrigens gar nicht gut.
Muss man ja echt mal sagen.
Das Einzige, was diese Teile können, ist,
zu checken und...
Die können doch nicht mal, die können doch nicht mal das.
Du musst selbst checken.
Mit Auge.
Du musst Auge, Auge machen.
Selbst da drauf.
Ob die Streifen parallel alle richtig leuchten,
der macht gar nichts, dieser Kabel-Tester.
Also wenn man wirklich ordentlich Kabel testen will,
gibt es schon recht günstige,
deutlich bessere Kabel-Tester,
die dann auch testen können, so...
Wie heißt das?
Übersprechen nennt sich das auf Deutsch.
Irgendwelche Tester.
Also...
Ist das nicht so, dass wenn ein Kabel geht,
dann geht es auch?
Das ist wie bei vielen Sachen.
Meistens sind Kabel-Probleme,
wenn wirklich was ganz kaputt ist,
geht oder geht nicht.
Aber du kannst ja beispielsweise auch die Isolierung
an einer Stelle kaputt gemacht haben.
Und du hast dann Probleme
ab einer gewissen Reichweite.
Oder hast nicht mehr die Signalqualität,
die du gerne hättest.
Du weißt ja im Endeffekt nicht,
wo es dran liegt.
Dein PoE funktioniert nicht
und du weißt nicht warum.
Gibt ja schon mehrere Möglichkeiten,
als geht es nicht.
Auch bei Kabel.
Kabel funktionieren tatsächlich.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Egal wie faszinierend das ist,
es ist super zu erfüllen.
Cut & Squeeze.
Das ist Perfektion.
Schau dir das an.
Ich bin in einem kleinen Glöckchen in meiner Wand.
Für die Kabel, die rauspöken.
Einige Backup-Backups und
eine Schaltung für das Internet.
Was ist denn das da, was er da hat?
Das ist eine USB-Festplatte?
Ist das überhaupt möglich?
Das erinnert mich an
Smurgo´s Torte.
Das ist Layer upon Layer.
Das ist eine USB-Festplatte.
Wo kommt all das Dreck her?
Das ist so ein Stealth-Bomber-Router.
Warum hat man sowas im Rack?
Warum sollte man sowas nicht ins Rack stellen?
Wenn man es hat, wenn man es verwendet,
soll man es vom Rack runterhängen lassen
oder wie, wenn Platz ist, stellt man es rein.
Ist doch gut.
Dafür ist das da.
Ein Rack, nur weil das 19 Zoll breit ist,
muss ja nicht nur zwangsläufig 19 Zoll Hardware auflegen.
Ich habe auch eine Schublade bei mir drinne.
Hier ist eine Schublade drinne.
Irgendwo.
Wenn man die sieht.
Ah ne, hier war ich gerade am umbauen.
Ich habe da auch eine Schublade drinne,
die man rein rausziehen kann.
Da steht zum Beispiel die Fritzbox drinne
und der Router.
Die sind halt einfach nicht 19 Zoll, bauweise.
Ach so, die USB-Festplatte.
Finde ich jetzt nicht schlimm, wenn die ihm reichen.
Ich bin der Meinung, man muss da pragmatisch sein
und es nicht übertreiben.
Wenn ich einfach nachts
mit AirSync mal einen Backup ziehen will
auf eine externe Platte, warum braucht man dann
warum will ich mir 19 Zoll Storage Zeug da reinhängen?
Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Externe Platte, gutes.
Man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Oftmals ist einfach
und nicht so ausfallsicher
unterm Strich in der Summe
doch ausfallsicherer.
Versteht man, was ich meine?
Weil, um was ordentlich ausfallsicher zu machen,
ist deutlich erhöhte Komplexität gefragt.
Meistens, zumindest.
Und durch diese deutlich erhöhte Komplexität
steigt die Chance,
dass man selbst Fehler macht,
was dann zu Ausfällen führt.
Und du kannst dich natürlich
so gut wie gar nicht durch
Bedienfehler-Ausfälle schützen.
Du kannst dich vor
Hardware-Fehler-Ausfälle schützen.
Also wenn du sagst, okay, ich hab Angst,
dass mein Server ausfällt
und der Service dann weg ist,
dann fängst du an mit,
okay, ich muss ein Cluster bauen.
Du baust ein Cluster mit zwei Kisten,
mit zwei Netzteilen drin, und dann stellst du fest,
sind zwei Cluster eher blöd.
Es muss eigentlich mindestens drei Nodes
in so einem Cluster sein.
Und wie verbinde ich das jetzt?
Ja, über einen Switch ist ja doof.
Wenn der Switch weg ist, dann denken alle,
es ist ein Master.
Das heißt, ich brauche so eine Art Internet-Connect.
Nicht Internet-Connect, Interconnect.
Am besten natürlich mit extra Netzwerkkarte nochmal
und untereinander verbunden.
Am besten doppelt miteinander verbunden.
Und dann endest du dann im Endeffekt
mit einem 3-Node-Cluster,
den du schön mit 1 Netzwerkkabel miteinander verbunden hast,
und dann siehst du irgendwas,
die Dinger haben eine doppelte IP
und es funktioniert nicht.
Du hast dann im Endeffekt mehr Ausfall dadurch,
als wenn du
eine Kiste hingestellt hättest,
einmal nächtlich ein Backup ziehst,
und wenn die Kiste wirklich mal kaputt geht,
du dir bei Amazon eine neue Kiste bestellst,
Tag später ist die da,
einbaust, Backup restorest,
und gut ist.
Da hast du zwei Tage Ausfall, okay,
mag sein,
bei den Sachen jetzt,
wenn man es ein bisschen dezentral gebaut hat,
bei sich daheim,
dass nicht alles auf einer zentralen Kiste drauf ist,
nicht so wild.
Also wenn jetzt mal meine Heimautomatisierung
zwei Tage nicht geht,
ist das wirklich sehr ärgerlich,
an einigen Stellen,
aber jetzt nicht lebensnotwendig,
dann kriege ich nicht angezeigt,
wie viel Verspätung der Zug hat,
ich kann nicht den Druck meiner Heizung nachgucken,
ich kann nicht den Druck meiner Heizung
nachgucken,
ich kann nicht das Ventil aufmachen
über das Tablet und sowas,
ja das ist doof,
aber ich kann beispielsweise auch
mein Licht hier oben an der Decke
nicht mehr gescheit steuern,
aber da komme ich mal zwei Tage mit aus,
und dann ist die Ersatzkiste da,
ich stöpsel die Festplatten um,
und es läuft wieder,
und sollte sich irgendwas da problematisch sein,
ziehe ich mir die Sachen von der externen Platte
als Backup.
Das wirkt irgendwie billig,
ich weiß, das wirkt nicht super technisch
sophisticated und advanced,
aber unterm Strich behaupte ich mal,
dass die meisten Leute
mit sowas, obwohl es ein
rechnerisch höheres Risiko hat,
kaputt zu gehen,
praktisch weniger haben,
weil die meisten Leute rechnen ja nur
Hardware Failure Rates mit ein,
in das Risiko,
aber eigentlich müsstest du ja da auch
ich bin zu doof es bedienen
Fehler Rates mit einrechnen.
Ja, falsch rum.
Guck mal, das ist ein
Robocock S5.
Sieht zumindest ein bisschen so aus.
So einen hatte ich auch mal.
Den nutze ich aber nicht mehr.
Ist auch so ein Ding,
wo ich festgestellt habe,
dass es mehr Arbeit macht,
als es bringt.
Staubsaugerroboter.
Ich bin immer noch in der Versuchung es mal zu testen,
mit einem neuen,
der eine Entleerstation,
also eine automatische Absaugestation hat.
Weil was mich da rein immer genervt hat ist,
der braucht ja mehrere Fahrten,
bis der den kompletten Stock hier sauber gemacht hat.
Der ist lahm,
und die Menschen,
die die Entleeren fahren,
kann er nicht machen,
weil du zwischendrin leeren musst.
Und mir macht es weniger Gedanken
und weniger Arbeit,
einfach ab und zu hier mal
mit so einem ganz klassischen Staubsauger
durchzuflitzen eine Viertelstunde,
als das Ding permanent
zu entleeren
und zu gucken,
ob er nicht dann vielleicht doch am Sessel hängt
oder so.
... und VR-Headsets.
...
Ja, das ist ein Fractal Design Gehäuse.
Das ist aber noch ein älteres,
weil das noch kein USB-C
hat, hier.
Also die neueren haben hier ein USB-C.
Was das ist, weiß ich beim besten
Willen nicht. Ist das vielleicht der Reset-Knopf?
Und die neuen haben
auch einen viereckigen Knopf,
keinen runden mehr.
Aber ich kann doch gucken, ich hab doch das alte
Fractal Design hier noch stehen.
Das ist der Reset-Knopf.
Ja.
Ich hab nämlich genau das hier neben mir stehen.
Das ist noch mein altes Case.
Ja. Das neue hat jetzt einen viereckigen Knopf.
Aber das ist auch kein Fractal Design
ähm...
Wie heißt das Ding? R5 oder so?
Mehr. Sondern das ist jetzt ein Mesh
Fractal Design Mesh irgendwas,
was ich hab. Da, wo die Wasserkühlung reinpasst.
Ja.
Egal. Bisschen älteres noch.
Aber das passt nicht.
Aber es passt nicht.
Always plan ahead!
After a month,
it finally arrived.
All the way from the blessed lands
of China. Ah!
My new router.
Okay.
They also sent our power brick
maracas.
Wetten? Der hat sich den gekauft, weil
um Surf The Home,
das er auf Youtube vorgestellt hat,
letztens. War auch ein nicer Channel.
Der stellt ja immer solche Mini-PCs vor,
die sich gut für Routers eignen.
Guter Channel, wenn man auf so Heim-Netzwerk
und Heim-Home-Lab-Sachen steht.
Der untersucht die Dinger immer ziemlich genau.
Und die Dinger, die der empfiehlt,
finde ich meistens auch gut.
Ich habe die Seite schon lange gelesen,
früher, bevor die einen YouTube-Channel haben.
Die sind ja auch erst seit 2-3 Jahren auf YouTube.
Aber ein guter Channel für so kleine Heim-Server
oder kleine selbstgebauten Netzwerksachen.
Finde ich nice.
Inside Mikrotiks New 2,5 N4G.
Guck mal, die haben 9. Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Das sieht doch tatsächlich...
Moment.
Das sind immer noch 20 normale Gigabits, oder?
Das sind keine 2... oder?
Oder? Was haben die da?
Das könnte tatsächlich ein sehr interessanter
Switch, beziehungsweise Router-Switch,
wie das Mikrotik nennt, sein.
Kostet?
Äh.
Aber wenn das alles 2,4...
Das ist preislich gar nicht mal schlecht.
25 Ports, 2,5 Gig.
Dann hast du 4 Ports, 2,5 Gig.
Und 2,40.
Das ist preislich gar nicht so schlecht,
weil ich vermute auch,
dass es nicht die allerschlechteste
Hardware-Ausstattung sein wird.
Was ist denn da drinne?
Ja, okay.
Es ist nicht die ganz miese CPU.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ganz, ganz brauchbar.
Ich mein, für jetzt...
Wenn du da
viel mitmachen möchtest in RouterOS,
wenn du da irgendwie planst, 600 Firewall-Regeln
drin zu haben oder so,
dann ist es
vielleicht nicht...
nicht unbedingt der Beste.
Aber für den Heimbereich mehr als ausreichend.
Wenn man das braucht.
Aber im Heimbereich
ist wahrscheinlich 20 Ports, 2,5 Gig
auch schon ein kompletter Overkill.
Ich bin echt zufrieden mit meinem
Edge-Switch,
den ich seit ein paar Jahren habe.
Also 10 Gigabit.
Ist aber, glaube ich, echt
eine ganz interessante Kiste.
Gerade für Leute, die eventuell
wirklich auch schon auf 40 Gig schielen
und viele 2,5 Gigabit-Ports
und 2,5 Gigabit-Geräte haben.
Mal Frage an euch, weil ich glaube, dass es überhaupt nicht
verbreitet ist.
Wie viele 2,5 Gigabit-Geräte
habt ihr?
Also ich habe
zwei.
Mein neuer Rechner und mein alter...
Mein neuer Desktop-Rechner
und mein alter Desktop-Rechner.
Der alte
Onboard tatsächlich.
Mein alter Desktop-Rechner hatte 10 Gigabit
Onboard.
Und ja,
mein neuer hat halt...
eine Karte drin,
die das könnte.
Aber muss er nicht.
Er ist per 10 Gig angebunden.
Also ich habe auch nur zwei Geräte.
Der Rest ist alles noch Oldschool-Gigabit.
Und ich bilde mir sogar ein,
ich habe noch irgendein uraltes 100 Mbit-Gerät.
Ich weiß aber gerade nicht, was es ist.
Was ist das?
Was habe ich da?
Raspberry Pi 3?
Waren die schon Gig?
Oder 100 Mbit-Netzwerk?
Die waren schon Gigabit, gell?
Ich bilde mir ein,
ich habe letztens...
100 Mbit-chen noch mal
Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Whatever.
Dann habe ich doch kein 100 Mbit mehr.
Was war das für ein Mainboard-Method?
Das kann ich dir sagen.
Ich habe doch ein Video dazu.
So, und nicht mein neuer Rechner.
Der hatten das nämlich nicht.
Mein alter Rechner.
Mein neuer Rechner?
Ist es der?
Ne, warte mal.
Vor 10 Jahren?
Ne.
Das ist noch ein älterer.
Dazwischen müsste es noch ein Video geben.
Ne.
Das ist der Xeon gewesen.
Wenn jetzt...
Wisst ihr, was geil wäre?
Eine ordentliche Suche auf YouTube.
Der da.
Der da ist es.
Der hat ein...
S-Rock Fatality Z370 Professional.
Leute, Professional Gaming.
Und der hat onboard eine 10 Gigabit-Karte.
Äh, 10 Gigabit-Nik.
Okay.
Gehabt.
Hier.
Und das schon vor Urzeiten gefühlt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es so wenig Rechner gibt, die das heutzutage haben.
Ja, und die kann halt auch alles dazwischen.
Also in der Regel können 10 Gigabit-Karten auch immer alles dazwischen.
Also 1, 2,5 und 5.
Ob die Dinger noch mit 100 sinken, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob eine aktuelle Netzwerkkarte da noch 10 Mbit oder 100 Mbit sinken würde.
Ja, die war...
Die wollen so ähnlich klingen, aber Fatality ist der ehemalige Quake-Spieler.
Der, glaube ich, auch Twitch streamt mittlerweile.
Der hat schon Business gemacht zu Zeiten.
Also mit Gaming schon Business gemacht.
Da haben die ganzen Leute, die heute was von Gaming-Business erzählen, noch in die Windel geschissen.
Das war eines der ersten richtig bekannten Pro-Gamer.
Der damit auch richtig Kohle gemacht hat, weil er an, ich glaube, erst mal an Creative oder so...
... die Namensrechte verkauft hat, um...
... um...
... um... mit seinem, ja, eigentlich, eigentlich Nickname, Produkte rauszubringen.
Und irgendwie ging es dann an ASRock vielleicht.
Der hat an Ferrari gewonnen oder keine Ahnung.
Möglich.
Jetzt gucken wir das aber nochmal schnell fertig.
Wir benutzen nicht das Stück Scheiße.
Aber der Router selbst...
Oh ja.
Rock solid.
Was haben wir?
Aber der Router selbst...
2,54.
4.
2,5 Gig.
Ich persönlich bin ja weggekommen von selbst gebauten beziehungsweise selbst installierten Rautern, seitdem ich mein Billig MikroTik Router habe, brauche ich das nicht.
Der ist günstig.
Und der hat mit RouterOS so ziemlich alle nur erdenklichen Features, die man so brauchen kann von einem Netzwerkgerät, in einem Webinterface.
In einem etwas gewöhnungsbedürftigen Webinterface.
Ja.
RouterOS Demo.
Also so sieht die Oberfläche von MikroTik Geräten aus.
Die erschlägt einen komplett.
Ja.
Gehen wir mal IP-File.
Also das erschlägt einen wirklich.
Aber du kannst damit nahezu alles, was du machen willst, machen.
Natürlich, wenn du ganz abgedrehte Sonderdinger machen möchtest, ist eine Linux-Kiste, wo du komplett freie Hand hast, immer noch am besten.
Aber so spontan fällt mir wenig ein, was du nicht machen könntest mit so einem MikroTik RouterOS Gerät.
Unter der Haube läuft da auch übrigens irgendein Linux.
Aber du kriegst halt hier ein ganz brauchbares Webinterface.
Um die Sachen zu konfigurieren.
Und du hast ja auch hier Terminal Access und sowas.
Ja, darf man jetzt hier nicht machen.
Und man bekommt auch für Noobs zur initialen Einrichtung kann man auch hier so einen Quick-Setup machen.
Aber wer ein bisschen advancedere Sachen machen möchte mit seinem Netzwerk, mit seinem Router, mit seinen Netzwerkgeräten, sind die RouterOS Dinger von MikroTik wirklich gut.
Weil das ist günstig.
Der Hex-POE kostet 50 Euro oder so.
Den gibt es ja gar nicht.
Gar nicht mehr.
Nur mal Beispielsweise.
Okay, gibt es noch, aber gibt es ein neueres Modell von.
Das ist das Ding, was ich habe hier als Router.
Hat damals 50 Euro gekostet.
Du bekommst 4, äh sogar 5, 5 POE, äh ne, 4.
4 POE, 1 Gig Ports.
Dann noch einen normalen SFP-Port, einen 1 Gig Port, das du aber glaube ich nicht zusammen verwenden kannst.
Ach ne, der hat POE.
In, so rum war das.
Ah ja, genau.
Also man könnte den Router selbst wiederum per POE betreiben.
Dass da Internet dran steht, ist komplett bescheuert.
Du kannst die Ports so konfigurieren, wie du willst.
Ja.
Und das ist die Oberfläche von dem Ding.
Also so sieht RouterOS bei allen MikroTik-Geräten aus.
Und das ist ein 50 Euro Router.
Der macht alles, was ich will.
Kann tausendmal mehr, als ich bräuchte.
Hat SSH-Access, Terminal-Access, Web-Interface.
POE, POE kriegst du ja prinzipiell bei selbstgebauten Routern nicht.
Es ist für mich echt so, ja, sorglos Ding.
Es ist ein bisschen kompliziert, ja.
Das gebe ich zu.
Gerade die WLAN-Config ist super weird.
Da muss ich auch immer nachgucken, ja.
WLAN-Config kannst du bei MikroTik ja auf 5 verschiedene Arten machen.
Äh, warte mal.
Genau, Bridge, WLANs.
Dann kannst du auf die Interfaces.
Irgendwie gehen, WLANs.
Und dann gibt es noch irgendwo einen eigenen WLAN-Punkt.
Der ist dann aber unter, keine Ahnung, wo der sich versteckt.
Da gibt es irgendwie, ne, Interfaces ist es, Interfaces.
Das habe ich gesucht.
Also das ist, äh, äh.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man es schafft,
WLAN-Settings so kompliziert zu machen.
WLAN-Settings sind eigentlich was relativ Simples.
Es gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder ist das ein Trunk.
Trunk-Port, so wie Cisco das nennen würde.
Oder ein Tagged-Port, heißt das da, glaube ich, gell.
Also im Prinzip ist der Unterschied, es ist ein Port, wo automatisch, wenn Traffic reingeht,
intern ein WLAN-Tag draufkommt und wieder entfernt wird beim Rausgehen,
weil die Endgeräte nichts mit WLANs anfangen können.
Das ist der Standardmodus eigentlich, ja.
Und dann gibt es quasi Trunk-Ports.
Die sind von Netzwerkgerät zu Netzwerkgerät kommuniziert.
Die sind von Netzwerk-Kommunikationen gedacht, wo Traffic drüberläuft, der getaggt ist in verschiedenste WLANs.
Also im Prinzip gibt es die zwei Sachen.
Und die einfachste Variante ist, ich glaube, ein Tagged-Port heißt das bei Cisco.
Das ist die ganz klassische WLAN-Konfiguration, die man kennt, wo man sagt,
dieser Port soll in WLAN, äh, ja, 1337 und fertig.
Das bedeutet dann, dass jeglicher Traffic, der dort reingeht,
an diesem Port getaggt wird.
Mit WLAN 1337 für die weitere, äh, ja, Bearbeitung in den Netzwerkgeräten.
Und so jeder Traffic, der rausgeht an diesem Port, dann das WLAN-Tag wieder entfernt kriegt,
weil die Endgeräte damit nichts anfangen können.
Ja, und die haben es super kompliziert gemacht hier bei MikroTik, diese ganze Geschichte.
Oder untagged.
Ich meine halt das ganz normale Config von,
dieser Port bekommt WLAN-Tag XY, ja.
Und dann gibt es ja noch die Kombination.
Dann gibt es ja noch ein bisschen die Kombination,
die Kombination aus beidem.
Du kannst ja auch einen Trunk-Port machen,
mit einem Default-WLAN-Port, äh, mit einem Default-WLAN-Tag.
Wobei ich dann nicht weiß, ob das, streng genommen,
da müssen wir die ganzen, unsere ganzen Cisco-Experts hier helfen.
Oder Access-Port heißt es, ja, kann sein.
Du kannst ja auch sagen, hier geht getaggter WLAN-Traffic drüber.
Alles, was angetaggt ist, soll in das und das Default-WLAN.
Das gibt es ja auch noch, so eine Kombi-Variante.
Das ist zum Beispiel ganz nützlich,
bei IPs, die wir hier haben,
bei IP-Telefonen, die sich erstmal ihre Config ziehen.
Das ist angetaggter Traffic.
Aber das Gerät selbst versteht dann WLANs,
nachdem es mal konfiguriert ist.
Nachdem es gebootet ist über DHCP oder so, ja.
Also du sagst dann einfach hier,
dieser Port hat Default-WLAN 5,
aber selbst erlaubt es darüber,
getaggter WLAN-Traffic im Port 1337 zu gehen.
Und dann macht das IP-Telefon, macht dann DHCP,
wird standardmäßig in WLAN 5.
WLAN 5 steht dann auch der DHCP-Server.
Das Ding bootet mit einer IP und dann macht es den VoIP-Traffic
über WLAN 1337 und taggt das selbst.
Die Kombinationsmöglichkeiten gibt es auch noch.
Ja.
Zumindest so sieht das MikroTik-Ding aus.
Und nachdem du nie PoE bekommst in so fertige Dinger,
finde ich, das ist ein super Kompromiss, ja.
Es hat bei weitem nicht die Power von so einer Kiste,
hat auch nur einen Gigabit-Port.
Aber an der Stelle brauche ich ja auch nicht mehr.
50 Euro.
Schön passiv gekühlt auch.
Nachdem da ein Linux draufgehauen wird,
wird mir früher oder später eh noch irgendwelche Spielereien draufhauen.
Bin mir nicht sicher, kann man bei OpenSense,
oder PFSense mittlerweile Container drauflaufen lassen,
wenn man Bock hat?
Ich persönlich würde ja hoffen, nein, dass das nicht geht,
weil die sollten sich darauf konzentrieren,
eine stabile Firewall-Netzwerk-Distribution bereitzustellen,
ohne irgendwelches komische Containermanagement noch drauf.
6 GB of storage for some reason.
Out with the old.
Wobei.
Ist das nicht sogar BSD?
Ist OpenSense und PFSense nicht sogar BSD?
Dann fällt das mit Linux-Containern eh flach.
Ich glaube, das ist BSD, gell?
Ja, dann vergisst, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich meine, Docker funktioniert, glaube ich, auch unter BSD,
wobei es dort selbstverständlich keine Linux-Container startet,
sondern halt eine eigene Container-BSD-Runtime hat,
die dann wahrscheinlich irgendwas BSD-native-mäßiges verwendet.
Ja, doch.
Wenn es kein Linux ist, erinnert mich da schon was dran.
Es sei denn, es gibt halt alles, was ich dafür brauche, auch für BSD.
Keine Erfahrung mit Docker unter BSD.
Ich meine, wenn Docker, wenn es eine OCI oder so kompatible Container-Runtime für BSD gibt,
dann geht das auch.
Kenn ich mich aber nicht mit aus.
Der Noctua-Lüft, der Beste!
The closet is gonna become its own case.
It needs to breathe.
Find ich übrigens...
Das mag...
Ich mag so pragmatische...
The closet is gonna become its own...
...case.
Ich hoffe, man sieht den jetzt noch mal.
Ich mag so pragmatische Sachen wie deine Lüfter reinstellen.
Das einzige Problem, was ich damit sehe, ist, dass das nicht staubdicht ist.
Und gerade drumherum und sowas hier hat immer viele Lücken.
Das wird verstaubt sein as fuck da drinnen.
Ich habe glücklicherweise in meinem Serverraum nicht so sehr das Problem,
weil das echt ein abgeschlossener, eigener Raum mit Tür ist.
Da kommt nicht so viel Staub rein, der nicht schon drinnen ist.
Und da ist wenig Staub drinnen.
Also ihr seht...
Ihr habt es ja hier gesehen in der alten...
In dem alten Video.
Die Kiste hier unten, die am Anfang auf dem Boden stand...
Hallo?
Ja, genau.
Die Kiste, die stand mehrere Jahre in diesem Serverraum.
Und ihr seht kaum Staub.
Ich habe es nicht sauber gemacht.
Warum soll ich eine Kiste, die ich ausbaue, sauber machen?
Kaum Staub.
Also da ist tatsächlich wenig drinnen.
So, wir müssen einige Hosen drücken.
Genau wie damals, als wir das Tier, das Tierladen, gekauft haben,
sie kleine Hosen drücken.
Nein, nicht in es, in die Kiste.
Es kam dazu, um es zu erbrechen.
Da muss auf jeden Fall, also wenn das ein Lüfter ist,
der mit der Außenwelt, mit dem äußeren Raum um diesen Schrank irgendwie in Kontakt steht,
da muss ein Staubfilter hin.
Ohne Staubfilter ist das Ding nach einem Jahr so eingestaubt, dass du das nicht verwenden willst.
Deswegen sagt man ja auch, ich muss jetzt nochmal unterbrechen, deswegen sagt man ja auch, wenn man ein Gehäuse mit Lüftern ausstattet, sollte man immer gucken, dass ein Überdruck, heißt das, im Gehäuse ist.
Also du solltest immer mehr Lüfter haben, die Luft in das Gehäuse reinblasen, als Lüfter, die es rausziehen.
Das heißt, du hast ein bisschen Überdruck im Gehäuse, das heißt, es kommt kein Staub von außen rein, sofern die Lüfter, die die Luft reinziehen, Staubfilter davor haben, logisch.
Also es sollten immer ein bisschen mehr Lüfter sein, die Luft reinpusten, als Luft, die rausgepustet wird.
Weil umgedreht, wenn du...
Moment, nee, erzähl ich gerade Mist? Erzähl ich Mist? Sekunde, Leute.
Chat, Chat, warum erzählt... Max, jetzt... Chat, warum hört mir keiner zu und sagt, ich erzähl Scheiße?
Andersrum.
Nee.
Wartet mal.
Nee, ist doch richtig. Nee, ist doch richtig, was ich gesagt hab.
Ja, es sollten immer mehr Lüfter reinpusten, als rauspusten.
Weil wenn du mehr Lüfter hast, die die Luft aus dem Gehäuse rausziehen...
Und erzeugt das einen Unterdruck im Gehäuse.
Ja, und das sorgt dafür, dass an anderen Stellen der Staub sich durch Lücken reinzieht.
Ja, richtig.
Schneidet er gerade Löcher in seine Tür?
Ja.
Ja, der Paul, das kann durchaus funktionieren.
Wenn halt nicht viel Staub in dem Raum ist.
Also, wenn er da jetzt keinen Staubfilter davor macht, ist das Ding nach einem Jahr voll.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wann mein China-Chinesen-Zeug kommt.
Ich hoffe ja auf Montag oder Dienstag.
Hä?
Ich denke, das macht der Router.
Ja.
Cool.
Du kannst einfach Dockers und andere Sachen in diesen kleinen Routern fahren.
Kleine Computer sind das, was sie eigentlich sind.
Der Powerbrick war auch viel besser.
Von Aliexpress in China zu bestellen, ist eine große Verhandlung.
Echt?
Was meinst du? Ich habe nur gute Erfahrungen mit Aliexpress bisher gemacht.
Ist da ein Staubfilter davor oder nicht?
Wenn nicht, ist das Ding so schnell voller Staub.
Drei Grad Unterschied.
Nicht schlecht.
Das sind 5-Volt-Noctua-Fans.
Mit unseren Kontrollern kannst du...
Da ist kein Staubfilter davor, oder?
Du kannst Noctua-Fans...
Man sieht es nicht richtig.
Aber wenn da keiner davor ist, dann ist das so...
Wie gesagt, ich gebe dem Ding, keine Ahnung, ein Dreivierteljahr oder so, ist das Ding komplett eingestaubt.
Mit unseren Kontrollern kannst du den Staubfilter auswählen.
Du kannst ihn direkt in einen USB-Port einbinden, wenn du willst.
Der Asus Tor.
2,5 GB.
Es ist in dem Fall egal, ob das rein- oder rauszieht, wenn es...
Ohne Staubfilter ist...
Das, was ich eben gesagt habe, mit dem Überdruck im Gehäuse, das funktioniert nur, wenn die Lüfter, die die Luft reinsaugen, einen Staubfilter davor haben.
Wie läuft das eigentlich mit Zoll bei Aliexpress?
Ja, Aliexpress macht das geschickt im Vergleich zu, wenn du Sachen aus den USA bestellst.
Aliexpress schickt das zuerst nach...
In die Niederlande.
Irgendwo.
Und von dort geht es dann weiter.
Innerhalb der EU.
Per DHL.
Oder per whatever.
Meistens DHL.
Oder Post.
PostNL übernimmt manchmal auch noch ein bisschen den Weitertransport.
Aber hier letztendlich kommt dann die Post oder das DHL-Auto.
Und dadurch, dass das dann quasi EU-Traffic ist, ist dann eh mit Zoll nichts.
Die machen die ganze Zollabfertigung und Einfuhrsachen.
Direkt dann am Hafen in den Niederlanden.
Und anscheinend sind die deutlich besser als die Amis mit dem...
Mit den ganzen Papieren.
Weil ich hatte noch nie Zollprobleme mit den China-Chinesen.
Bei den Amis jedes Mal, wenn ich aus den USA bestellt habe, deswegen bestelle ich nicht mehr aus den USA, jedes Mal Zollprobleme.
Am schlimmsten war der Zoll in Leipzig.
Oder beziehungsweise DHL, die sich um den Zoll in Leipzig kümmern kann.
Hab ich angerufen, hab die gefragt, wie es aussieht.
Und dann meinten sie...
Das kann ich ihnen auch nun nüscht sagen.
Nüscht.
Nüscht sagen.
Kann ich ihnen das.
Ach ja, gut.
Schön, dass ich angerufen hab.
Und die Chinesen kriegen das besser hin.
Wie auch immer die das machen, vielleicht schreiben die auch einfach Bullshit drauf, der nicht stimmt.
Womit die Zollleute dann zufrieden sind.
Oder es ist schlicht und ergreifend so viel auf diesen Containerschiffen drauf, dass die das Pi mal Daumen machen.
So, ah ja, wird schon passen.
So, hopp, wir haben einen neuen Router.
2 Backup-Backups.
Die Medium NAS.
Und die größte dickere.
Hohoho.
Sehr gut.
Ich mag dieses Scheiß.
Abonniert heute mehr RAM.
Hat noch ganz ordentlich gemacht.
Wie gesagt, ich mach mir nur ein bisschen Gedanken über Staub da drinnen.
Chat, ich hab ho...
Alter, wie bin ich bitte schon schon 3 Stunden 15 on?
Wir haben zwei Videos geguckt oder so.
Wie hat denn das wieder funktioniert?
Oder drei?
Drei Videos.
Hast du deine...
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Wo denn?
Wie unterscheidet es uns zwischen...
Poste nochmal.
Ich guck gleich.
Wie unterscheidet es uns
zwischen gutem, absoluten und schlechtem?
Das ist eine...
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich würde es mal als Bauchgefühl
zusammenfassen.
Also ich guck mir auch ein bisschen
die Bewertung an,
wobei du da bei AliExpress
wenig drauf geben kannst.
Schwer zu sagen.
Echt schwer zu sagen,
woran ich das an AliExpress festmache.
Also ich guck mir halt an,
wie die Anzahl...
Also wie die...
AliExpress, muss man ja wissen,
AliExpress ist ja quasi
ein großer Marketplace
mit ganz vielen Shops drin.
AliExpress selbst verkauft ja da nix.
Also...
Glaub ich zumindest.
Also das meiste sind Shops.
Also ich guck mir an,
ein bisschen,
wie die Shop-Seite so aussieht
und...
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
ist das Bauchgefühl,
wenn ich mir denke,
ja,
sieht nicht total billig
und unprofessionell aus,
dann klappt das meistens.
Und ich hab schon recht...
Also ich mein,
ich hab jetzt keine tausend Sachen
oder so keine Sample-Size
von tausend Bestellungen,
wo ich sagen kann,
tausend Sachen bestellt
und 995 ohne Probleme.
Nee, ich hab vielleicht insgesamt so
50, 60 Sachen oder so,
oder so,
bei AliExpress bestellt.
Und so richtig große Probleme
hatte ich noch nie.
Ich hatte einmal eine Bestellung,
die kam nicht an.
Aber da hat AliExpress
sehr schnell drauf reagiert
und mein Geld zurück überwiesen.
Und mit viel weniger Problemen,
als ich mit dem PayPal-Käuferschutz hatte.
Weil AliExpress hat das umgedreht.
AliExpress hat einfach gesagt,
wenn man als Kunde
nicht nach 48 Stunden sagt,
ja, es wurde zu meiner...
zu meiner Zufriedenheit gelöst,
kriegst du einfach dein Geld zurück.
Nicht so wie bei PayPal.
Ah, sie haben nicht reagiert.
Case geschlossen.
AliExpress hat den Verkäu...
AliExpress...
Also, Problem war,
ich hab was bestellt,
die haben mir eine Versandnummer,
äh,
Tracking-Nummer bestellt,
das hat ich einfach nix getan.
Ja, bestimmt eine Woche war nix getan.
Hab ich da hingeschrieben,
hab gesagt,
oh, sorry, ja,
hier haben sie eine neue Tracking-Nummer.
Die neue Tracking-Nummer
war ja die alte Tracking-Nummer
und wo sich dann wieder
ein paar Tage nix getan hat.
Dann hab ich an den AliExpress-Käuferschutz
äh,
geschrieben
und die haben gesagt,
okay, sie kontaktieren den Verkäufer,
haben sie geschrieben,
ja, Verkäufer wurde kontaktiert,
ähm,
bitte sagen sie Bescheid
innerhalb von 48 Stunden,
ob sich das Problem erledigt hat.
Problem hat sich nicht erledigt,
weil die haben mir nochmal
die gleiche Tracking-Nummer geschickt,
wo sich nix getan hat
und haben gesagt,
äh,
bitte haben sie noch etwas Geduld
und da hab ich einfach mal gedacht,
okay, was passiert dann,
wenn ich nicht reagiere?
Hab ich 48 Stunden nicht reagiert,
AliExpress hat das Ding geclosed
und mir mein Geld zurück überwiesen.
Und,
die Sendung kam auch nie an.
Das heißt,
die haben mir von Anfang an Bullshit erzählt,
von wegen, es wär schon in Transit.
Ja, das war das einzige Problem,
was ich je hatte.
Ansonsten, ich hab 50, 60 Sachen da oder so schon bestellt.
Also Bestellung, nicht Sachen,
Sachen insgesamt mehr.
50, 60 Mal oder so,
da bestellt schon.
Und,
außer einmal,
das, ich hatte nie Probleme.
Ich hab da aber auch nur Technik-Zeug bestellt.
Ich hab da noch nie,
ja, du kannst ja bei AliExpress
den größten Bullshit bestellen, ja,
von, äh,
Hair Extensions,
äh,
zu,
keine Ahnung,
gefälschten Zähnen oder so.
Alles.
Es gibt auf AliExpress
die wirsten Sachen, ja.
Oder du kannst ja auch bei AliExpress
auch so medizinische Geräte bestellen.
Da gibt es Geräte,
die, äh,
sollen dir angeblich
Muttermale rausschneiden können.
Alter, wer sich sowas
kauft bei AliExpress
und benutzt,
ist lebensmüde.
Also, das ist einfach nur dämlich.
Da gehst du zum Hautarzt,
wenn du Probleme hast,
aber bestellst du nicht bei AliExpress
einen Muttermale-Entferner.
Aber Microcontroller,
Technikzeug,
ich hab mir bei AliExpress
auch mal
ein 50er-Pack
USB-Kabel bestellt.
Kam an, ohne Probleme.
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen,
Max,
was willst du mit 50 USB-Kabeln?
Da muss ich euch leider sagen,
ich weiß es bis heute
selbst nicht so genau.
Also, ich hab davon
bestimmt noch
40 rumliegen,
die ich nie gebraucht hab,
aber die sind da.
50er-Pack, ja.
Aber für genau sowas
ist AliExpress gut.
Zum Beispiel 50 USB-C.
Das ist einfach
verlosen.
Was muss denn da verlosen, Alter?
So.
Und das ist halt echt
konkurrenzlos billig.
Guck mal hier.
Du bestellst,
du kannst dir hier
1 Meter
USB-Kabel bestellen.
Ähm,
nein, nein, nein,
das sind 50.
Und das kostet 23 Euro.
Das sind 50 Cent
pro USB-Kabel.
Und nachdem die meisten
USB-Kabel,
die in der Barmherzogt,
wo du so und so bestellen kannst,
auch China-Chinesen-Kram sind,
sind die wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mal so viel schlechter
als die 0,15 USB-Kabel
von Amazon.
So, 100 kosten,
ja, ist doppelt ungefähr.
Ah,
die, die weltbekannte Marke
AEVVKIF.
Alles klar.
Wer kennt sie nicht?
AEVVKIF.
Bestellen bitte.
Nee, brauch ich nicht.
Ich hab noch genug USB-Kabel.
Ich hab mir da mal
damals einen 50er-Pack bestellt.
Micro-USB-USB-C-Kombokabel.
Ich glaube,
ich hab die auch nicht so oft verwendet,
weil ich die,
die Buchse vorne kacke finde
mit dieser extra Sache für USB-C.
Vielleicht soll ich mir nochmal
einen 50er-Pack USB-C bestellen.
Aber ich hab,
ich hab einfach,
ich hab schon mehr als,
ich hab ne komplette Schublade voll
mit USB-Kabel.
Und es ist eine große Schublade.
Es ist quasi eher
so ein alter Amazon-Karton voll.
Da sind bestimmt,
keine Ahnung,
250 USB-Kabel oder so drin,
die sich mittlerweile angesammelt haben.
Ich brauch keine USB-Kabel.
Plus die,
die Dinger,
die ich von AliExpress bestellt hab,
die sind noch in einer anderen Kiste drin.
Freu dich.
Also für so Sachen
ist AliExpress unschlagbar günstig.
Und der Kram,
und die meinen das ernst, ja,
der Kram kommt auch immer ziemlich gut an.
Ihr könnt sogar filtern bei AliExpress
nach Versand von.
Ja, also man kann hier zum Beispiel,
das ist bei AliExpress
immer übelst
beknackt gemacht.
Ja, aber hier,
er kann sagen,
Versand from Germany.
Äh, oder,
okay, mein Dark Reader
macht komische Dinger.
Ja, du kannst sogar aus EU gucken.
Ja, hier gibt's welche Sachen,
die werden von Germany,
was auch immer das mit 50 USB-C
jetzt zu tun hat.
Die AliExpress-Suche
ist noch wirrer
als die Amazon-Suche.
Also,
ich wollt mich schon auch immer
so eine 100-Zoll-Winde
bestellen bei AliExpress.
Also das ist so ein Ding,
also eine Winde,
wo ich vielleicht
selbst,
mich dranhänge,
weil ich irgendwie
da klettern muss oder so,
die würde ich nicht unbedingt
bei AliExpress bestellen.
Ja, also,
alles, wo es um Leben und Tod geht,
ist AliExpress
nicht unbedingt
meine erste Wahl.
Oder auch halt alles,
wo es in die Tausende
an Schaden geht,
wenn was kaputt geht,
ist nicht meine erste Wahl.
Also zum Beispiel
würde ich keine Batterien
bestellen bei AliExpress.
Bei China-Chinesen-Batterien
hätte ich viel zu viel Schiss,
dass die mir kaputt gehen
und abfackeln.
Ja, da brennt dir die Bude ab,
wegen 2 Euro gespart
für eine Batterie.
Was, was für einen Widerspruch?
Keine mit dem Ladekabel,
warum?
Warum?
Bei einem USB-Kabel,
das ist,
das kommt eine USB-Buchse,
da hast du 5 Volt
und was,
was geht da maximal
zum Laden
bei so einem,
bei so einem ollen Ding,
1, 2 Ampere?
Das ist doch ein bisschen
was anderes,
wie, äh,
Akkus, die abfackeln können
oder gar Sachen,
die du irgendwie
an 230 Volt betreibst,
an der Stelle.
Das ist doch ein bisschen
eine Schreckdose.
Schon mal Storage
auf AliExpress bestellt?
Du meinst SSDs und sowas?
Ne.
Hab ich nicht.
Biles ist mittlerweile
gar nicht mehr so viel günstiger
auf AliExpress,
wie wenn du es dir direkt
bei Amazon kaufst.
Storage gehört da,
glaube ich, mit dazu.
Das einzige, was geht,
ist diese super billigen
Drecks-USB-Sticks,
die schon mal jeder hatte,
die es da immer
im 100er-Pack gibt.
Diese Dinger,
die hatte jeder schon mal.
Chat,
Hand hoch,
wer diesen USB-Stick
schon mal hatte.
Das sind halt
die allergrößten
Billig-Schrott-Dinger.
Die haben so
einen Kilobyte
pro Sekunde
Transferspeed.
Das ist halt...
Also,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Anscheinend,
das soll
ein Holzofen sein.
Ja, die Beschreibung
bei AliExpress
ist oftmals
ziemlich,
ziemlich merkwürdig.
Das sieht aus
wie ein Heizluftgerät.
Holzofen-Werkzeug.
Die China-Chinesen,
man, Alter.
Nee, das ist doch nicht...
Ist das...
Ist das einfach
nur eine hässlich aussehende
Lötkolben,
oder was ist das?
Ach nee,
das ist so,
wo du Sachen
irgendwie reingravieren kannst.
Holzofen, Alter.
Ja,
da muss man sich
bei AliExpress
dran gewöhnen,
dass die...
dass die Beschriftung
ziemlich bescheuert ist
oftmals.
Ja, in Deutschland
sind wir da immer
ein bisschen merkwürdig drauf
mit solchen Sachen.
Die könnten sich die AGBs
auch einfach im Internet angucken.
Zumindest eigentlich
mag ich sagen,
ihr könnt hier mittlerweile
noch nach Land filtern,
wovon das Ganze
verschickt wird.
Da könnt ihr euch dann sicher sein,
dass das auch pünktlich ankommt.
Ja, also,
das ist was,
hier wäre ich zum Beispiel
persönlich ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Solche...
Das sind ja
für Ladegeräte
fürs Auto,
die du nur,
wenn du einen Anzug anhast,
richtest,
richtig benutzen kannst.
Da weiß ich nicht so genau,
ob ich mich da
auf AliExpress-Sachen
verlassen würde.
Da sind...
Die meisten Sachen
wären,
was sind das?
400 Volt
und bis zu...
Was ist denn das?
Was macht denn so eine normale...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube,
11 Kilowatt
ist so die normale
Ladestation,
die man ohne Genehmigung
daheim
haben kann.
Ich glaube,
wenn man so ein Auto
haben darf,
da habe ich ein bisschen Bedenken...
Humanized Design.
Ah ja,
okay.
Da hätte ich halt
so ein bisschen Bedenken
damit,
mit so einem AliExpress-Dinger
mein Elektroauto zu laden.
Also,
das sind so die Sachen,
da traue ich denen
nicht so ganz.
Aber für Elektronik-Kleinteile
ist das super.
Ja,
wenn man sich hier
zum Beispiel...
Der Klassiker,
ja?
Irgendein ESP32.
Wobei es sie mittlerweile
auch in Deutschland
relativ günstig
zu kaufen gibt.
Aber,
die sind halt hier immer noch...
echt
konkurrenzlos
günstig.
Wenn man hier mal
nach so einem D1 Mini
guckt,
auf AliExpress,
guck mal,
das ist so...
Hier bezahlst du
6 Euro
oder 3,50 Euro
pro Ding.
Also,
wenn man sowas...
Das ist wirklich
konkurrenzlos billig
oftmals auf AliExpress
sowas.
Wobei das ein Fake
D1 Mini ist.
Das ist ein
Feiyang
D1 Mini.
Das ist kein offizieller
Wemos D1 Mini.
Aber,
die Dinger tun,
ja.
Auch wenn man halt
irgendwelche Bauteile braucht,
ja.
Also,
zum Beispiel hier
Ultraschall...
Schall...
Sensor.
Ich kann das schreiben.
Ultraschall...
Sensor.
Ja.
So Dinger hier.
Das ist
unschlagbar
günstig.
Bei AliExpress
solche Sachen.
Und,
deswegen kaufe ich auch immer...
Ich hab's euch ja schon mal
immer...
Ich hab's euch schon oft
erzählt.
Ich kaufe keine einzelnen
Teile mehr.
Ich kaufe immer nur
mindestens 3er Packs.
Und bei AliExpress
bei sowas nehme ich auch
5er und 10er Packs.
Weil du da 5 Stück kriegst
für das, was du hier
einbezahlst.
Hast du eine Idee,
wie man am besten
die FFmpeg-Parameter lernet?
Hätte gerne eine C-Sharp-Web-APD-Videos
streamt mit der ALS
und einer, die
streamt mit der...
Die Examples angucken.
Also du willst ja nicht
FFmpeg
per Kommandozeile machen.
Du willst ja die FFmpeg-Library
verwenden.
Vermutlich mal,
ja.
Da hätte ich jetzt so spontan
auch gar keine Ahnung,
wie ich das
machen würde.
Also HLS
muss man wahrscheinlich
dann über C-Sharp machen.
Man bekommt wahrscheinlich
die Video-Häppchen
dann von FFmpeg.
Das streamen müsstest du
irgendwie über C-Sharp machen.
Und Adaptive Bitrate,
ja, je nachdem,
was FFmpeg...
Also,
ich hätte jetzt
spontan keine Idee,
wie ich es mit FFmpeg
bauen würde.
Aber ich würde mir
die Examples angucken.
Es gibt von FFmpeg...
Ach so, du würdest
die CLI verwenden.
Aber wie willst du das
dann mit deiner
.NET-Sache integrieren?
Also ich meine,
du brauchst,
also FFmpeg...
Ach so,
du willst FFmpeg
als Browser starten
und sowas.
Ja, das geht.
Das geht.
Ja,
Kommandozeilen-Parameter
ist FFmpeg
extrem wirr.
Da bleibt nur
Stack-Overflow.
Copy-Paste
bis es funktioniert.
Okay, Leute.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt
was fressen.
Lachs mit Nudel
grüner Sauce.
Okay,
danke schön
für den Sub.
Ich schau mal kurz.
Ob ich nicht irgendjemand
vergessen habe,
weil das wollen wir
ja nicht.
Duxdun.
Dich habe ich...
Du hast nur gefollowt,
aber erwähnen wir
trotzdem mal.
Übrigens,
wenn euch die Streams
gefallen,
ich freue mich über
jeden Follower.
Ich bin...
Ich kann nicht mehr
reden, Alter.
Ich lasse es bleiben.
Ich wollte sagen,
ich bin in nächster Zeit
auch wieder öfters
on.
Jetzt bin ich auch wieder
ganz gesund.
MMO-Kreisel-Client
muss trotzdem sein.
Hat jemand aus dem Chat
oder eine Idee,
an was es liegen kann,
die sich nicht performt?
Ja,
an IPsec wahrscheinlich.
Auf der PSNC Proxy
läuft er ja auch,
ne?
Ja,
ich vermute mal,
dass du nicht
auf die Crypto-Extensions
deiner CPU
und hat deine
hat deine CPU
überhaupt Crypto-Extensions,
je nachdem,
worauf du das laufen hast?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass die
VM
nicht checkt,
dass deine
CPU Crypto-Extensions
hat.
Das kannst du testen
mit OpenSSL
oder
mit
OpenSSL
oder
mit
OpenSSL
OpenSSL Benchmark
machen
und gucken,
wie viel durchgeht.
Es gibt
bestimmt mittlerweile
bessere Tests
auf die Crypto-Extensions.
Mach mal
Dings hier.
ähm
Cat Proc
CPU Info
auf der VM
und dann musst du gucken,
ob die Crypto-
Boah,
keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht,
was da von die Crypto-Extensions
AES irgendwas,
ne?
Gibt es hier sowas wie AES?
Soll ich mal
eine AES ketten?
Okay,
tatsächlich.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das
AES ist.
Ja,
hier.
sowas musst du gucken.
Wobei,
wobei ich mich da nicht
darauf verlassen würde,
dass das auch alles richtig
durchgereicht wird dann.
Ja.
Guck,
ob deine CPU
das hier hat
oder
das deiner CPU
entsprechende.
Wenn die CPU auch
AES in der VM hat,
dann weiß ich's nicht.
Vielleicht ist das
IPSec
ohne
Crypto-Extensions Support
kompiliert?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Da musst du suchen.
Mal gucken,
weil
2,5 Gig
quasi
Saturated
normal
und 280 MBit
mit Crypto-Extensions
erscheint mir doch
ein wenig
sehr
wenig.
Der AES-NI
heißt das Feature.
In CPU-Flex
heißt es,
glaube ich,
nur AES.
Bei AMD
heißt es,
glaube ich,
noch anders
und bei ARM-CPUs
auch irgendwie anders.
Döner bestellen?
Nein.
Ich futter Lachs
mit Nudel
und grüner Sauce.